bien mes chers collègues
bonsoir tout d'abord notre commission
commence donc ce soir et poursuivra
demain jeudi et peut-être vendredi la
mission pour laquelle elle a été
constituée à savoir l'examen du projet
de loi numéro 1443 relatif à l'industrie
verte je salue immédiatement votre nom à
tous le ministre Roland Lescure monsieur
mélise bonsoir que certains d'entre nous
un peu plus anciens que d'autres seront
peut-être tentés d'appeler ce soir le
président Lescure ne vous gênait pas il
a de l'humour puisque vous avez présidé
monsieur le ministre destiné de la
commission des affaires économiques sous
la 15e législature d'ailleurs ça doit
vous faire un peu bizarre que je sois à
cette place là mais bon on va s'y faire
je souhaite également la bienvenue à
notre collègue Charles sisten soul
j'arrive jamais à le dire Charles je
suis désolé c'est trop compliqué tu me
donneras ton nom par phonétique la
prochaine fois membre de la commission
des finances et qui a récemment présenté
au nom de la commission des affaires
européennes un rapport d'information
[Musique]
sur ce texte à savoir chapitre 1 du
Titre 1 monsieur Guillaume kasbariian
président de la commission des affaires
économiques et rapporteur général sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi chapitre 2
du Titre 1 Madame Christine Decotte
chapitre 3 et 4 du Titre 1 madame Marie
Agnès poussiévinceback chapitre 5 du
Titre 1 monsieur Guillaume gaz barian au
titre de Madame Anne Laure Babeau et au
titre 3 monsieur Damien Adam le projet
de loi dont nous allons débattre a fait
l'objet de 1415 amendements j'ai été
conduit à déclarer
271 amendements irrecevables au titre
des dispositions de l'article 45 de la
Constitution un ensemble d'amendements a
été soumis au président de la commission
des finances dans le cadre du contrôle
de recevabilité au titre des
dispositions de l'article 40 de la
Constitution et 35 amendements n'ont pas
franchi ce filtre par ailleurs un
amendement a été déclaré irrecevable
comme constitutif d'une injonction
au gouvernement et 5 et recevables au
titre du respect du périmètre d'une
habilitation allégérée par voie
d'ordonnance compte tenu des amendements
retirés ou scinder pour une meilleure
lisibilité de nos débats ce sont au
total 1044 amendements que nous aurons à
examiner dans les heures qui viennent
je donnerai donc successivement la
parole au ministre Roland Lescure à nos
rapporteurs au rapporteur de la
commission des affaires européennes au
groupe politique et aux orateurs
individuels pour la discussion générale
je vous propose les modalités
d'organisation suivante pour le
rapporteur général et les rapporteurs
thématiques dans l'ordre du texte 5
minutes chacun pour notre collègue
Charles site
stand soul c'est mieux ou pas Charles
merci rapporteur de la commission des
affaires européennes 5 minutes pour les
groupes politiques trois minutes par
groupe le ministre répondant ensuite
s'il le souhaite de façon groupée à
l'ensemble des groupes qui se seront
exprimés pour les questions
individuelles une minute par orateur le
ministre répondant ensuite de la même
manière de façon groupée à l'ensemble
des questions qui lui auront été posées
pour l'examen des amendements et compte
tenu du nombre d'amendements examinés
les modalités seront les suivantes une
minute trente pour défendre l'amendement
les avis du rapporteur et du
gouvernement un or ateur pour un orateur
contre à raison d'une minute chacun sauf
naturellement si l'importance
particulière du sujet justifiait des
échanges un peu plus longs
il y a-t-il des questions
non alors sans plus tarder et afin de
d'entrer sans tarder dans le vif du
sujet je passe la parole au ministre
Roland Lescure monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur général
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames et messieurs les députés ce
n'est pas sans une certaine émotion que
je me retrouve à ce banc où j'ai
effectivement vous l'avez dit siéger
quelques années dans votre siège qui
était plus confortable que le mien
d'ailleurs je comprends que le président
un siège à accoudoir pour ceux qui ne
sont jamais passés de l'autre côté du
vent et je m'y étais habitué
je voudrais d'abord commencer par
excuser Bruno Le Maire qui n'a pas pu
être parmi nous ce soir vous avez bien
compris que les circonstances actuelles
font que le gouvernement est un peu
occupé à plusieurs sujets d'actualité
qui sont pour le moins brûlants il a
beaucoup travaillé avec Olivier Grégoire
sur le soutien à nos commerçants il y
est encore ce soir et donc il m'a
demandé de prononcer en mon nom mais
aussi en son nom une déclaration
générale qui vise à vous présenter les
éléments principaux de ce projet de loi
dit industriel verte ce projet de loi
arrive donc aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée en
commission spéciale après des
discussions
instructives intéressante constructive
et apaisé au Sénat menant vous l'avez
sans doute vu un très large soutien je
viens devant vous maintenant présenter
ce projet de loi qui est j'en suis
convaincu un véritable tournant pour
notre économie
il poursuit une ambition stratégique
l'accélération de la réindustrialisation
de la France grâce à une révolution
verte il doit mettre définitivement fin
à ce qui a été une faute économique une
faute sociale une faute écologique cette
faute c'est une aire de
désindustrialisation massive dans nous
sortons à peine
aucune entre aucune autre part dans
nation occidentale ne s'est autant
affaibli vous le savez la part de
l'industrie est passée de 22% à 11% du
PIB entre 1973 et 2018 là où elle est
restée stable en Allemagne et stable en
Italie nous avons perdu 2,5 millions
d'emplois industriels une véritable
catastrophe si cette part s'est
stabilisée depuis 2018 à environ 11% du
PIB notre projet a vocation à accroître
cette part de l'industrie
c'est pour mettre fin à ce désastre que
nous avons agi avec le président de la
République pour ouvrir donc une nouvelle
aire de réindustrialisation nationale et
européenne depuis 2017 nous avons vous
avez baissé les impôts de société vous
avez baissé les impôts de production car
il n'y a pas d'industrie sans capital
nous avons misé sur la formation en
faisant de l'apprentissage d'avoir
royale d'accès à l'emploi nous avons
simplifié l'ouverture de site industriel
avec la loi pacte dont j'avais l'honneur
d'être le rapporteur général et donc
certains rapporteurs sont présents dans
cette salle ce soir nous avons enfin
lancé le plan France 2030 et relancer la
construction de réacteurs nucléaires
ces résultats sont sans appel avec une
France qui est désormais la nation la
plus attractive pour les investissements
en Europe avec un solde positif sur
l'ensemble du quinquennat précédent de
300 ouvertures d'usines en net dont deux
sens et deux dernières années avec la
création de près de 100 000 emplois
industriels et avec la construction qui
débute de nouvelles filières comme celle
des batteries électriques
nous avons également une base européenne
avec le président de la République là
encore nous avons mené cette révolution
idéologique
consistant à laisser les États membres
apportés des soutiens financiers au
développement de leur industrie sous
forme de subventions ou sous forme de
crédit d'impôt
sur cette base mesdames et messieurs les
députés nous avons trois choix
politiques possibles le premier c'est le
statu quo on continue comme avant la
croissance pour la croissance
l'ouverture de site pour l'ouverture de
site peu importe le climat ce statu quo
est une impasse car il n'est pas durable
et serait synonyme de coût vertigineux
pour les finances publiques les
assureurs et les particuliers puisqu'on
produirait aujourd'hui les sources des
catastrophes de demain
le deuxième choix qui s'offre à nous
c'est celui de la décroissance qui
signifierait l'approvision
l'approvisionnement pardon de nos
compatriotes et la relégation du pays
concrètement elle représente un modèle
social qu'on ne financerait plus moins
de soins moins de technologie moins de
transport faire le choix de la
décroissance c'est faire le choix de
vivre moins bien de vivre probablement
replié sur soi et puis surtout c'est
faire un choix qui est dans mon point de
vue non crédible parce qu'en réalité
qu'on le veuille au nom nos compatriotes
ne vont pas arrêter d'acheter des
voitures on espère électrique d'acheter
des vélos qu'on espère aussi électrique
d'acheter des pompes à chaleur au lieu
d'acheter des produits fabriqués sur
notre territoire ils apporteront les
mêmes produits fabriqués ailleurs dans
des conditions moins respectueuses de
l'environnement nous serons perdants sur
tous les tableaux ni vers ni prospère
la troisième option et c'est celle que
nous vous proposons d'adopter
aujourd'hui c'est la croissance verte
une croissance qui se fait en réduisant
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
c'est le cœur de ce projet de loi de
l'industrie verte je suis convaincu
qu'il s'agit d'une chance qui va nous
permettre d'ouvrir des usines d'innover
de créer plus de richesses tout en
réduisant nos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre
qu'est-ce que l'industrie verte je pense
qu'on va passer un certain temps ce soir
à tenter de la démission de la définir
pour nous c'est très simple ce n'est pas
un oxymore l'industrie peut être verte
l'industrie en fait droit doit pardon
être verte l'industrie verte pour nous
ce sont deux stratégies complémentaires
d'abord la décarbonation de l'industrie
traditionnelle c'est une nécessité
l'industrie traditionnelle représente
aujourd'hui environ 20% des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre en France nous
devons les réduire nous nous sommes
engagés en Europe vous le savez à
réduire l'ensemble des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre en net à 0 d'ici 2050
et elle est divisée par deux d'ici 2030
donc le premier défi de ce projet de loi
c'est de favoriser la décarbonation de
l'industrie traditionnelle et le
deuxième défi de ce projet de loi s'est
produire massivement des technologies
vertes qu'on appelle les Big Five les
pompes à chaleur l'éolien le
photovoltaïque les batteries et
l'hydrogène vert
ce n'est donc pas une contradiction
c'est une évidence car c'est grâce à
l'industrie que la France deviendra la
première négation pardon des carbonées
en Europe comment allons-nous y réussir
ce projet de loi procède par étape à
partir d'une question simple de quoi
avons-nous besoin pour construire des
usines vertes et pour les faire tourner
il est court il est incisif et il
propose des instruments qui vont changer
la donne
premier élément important nos
industriels ont besoin de foncier le
foncier industriel vous le savez il est
rare en France nous prendrons donc avec
vous deux mesures radicales la première
c'est mettre à disposition de
l'industrie 56 intégralement dépollués
représentant dominectares grâce à
l'action de la banque des territoires
qui s'engage à y consacrer un milliard
d'euros d'ici 2027
la deuxième mesure qui vise à simplifier
l'accès aux fonciers elle est importante
elle est originale elle est d'une
certaine manière révolutionnaire c'est
rehausser la créance environnementale au
rang des créances privilégiées le but
est de récupérer 25% des sommes
nécessaires pour dépolluer les friches
le deuxième élément essentiel que les
industriels nous mentionnent quand il
s'agit de venir s'installer en France
pour ceux qui viennent de l'étranger ou
pour élargir leurs installations pour
ceux qui sont déjà ici c'est évidemment
la simplification et l'accélération des
procédures
première mesure qui vise à
l'accélération et à la simplification
elle est simple divisée par deux les
délais d'ouverture ou d'agrandissement
d'une usine en France de 17 mois réels
aujourd'hui la réalité c'est 17 mois en
moyenne à 9 mois réel demain nous
passerons d'une procédure dite
successive qui enchaîne les procédures
les unes après les autres avec souvent
d'ailleurs des délais entre chacune
d'entre elles à une processus à une
procédure pardon dite parallèle c'est un
changement radical il est radicalement
efficace il est radicalement nouveau il
se fera sans affecter je sais que vous y
êtes sensible et exigences
environnementales ni la consultation
publique dont nous accroissant la durée
elle passera de un mois à trois mois
deuxième mesure sur l'accélération des
procédures elle concerne les projets
d'intérêt national majeurs un certain
nombre d'entre vous en ont dans leur
circonscription une procédure
d'exception sera mise en place pour
quelques projets
identifiés par des craies l'état prendra
la main de manière à accélérer les
procédures sur leur accordement
électrique le permis de construire ou
encore la modification du PLU cette
procédure elle est nécessaire pour
attirer des investissements en France
celle de plus grands investisseurs et
tout en conservant cette ambition je
précise que nous soutenons une meilleure
prise en compte de la vie des élus
c'était important pour les sénateurs je
sais que c'est important aussi pour vous
et en particulier des mers et des
responsables de PCI on ne construit pas
une usine contre un territoire ni contre
ses représentants
troisième élément essentiel là aussi je
sais qu'il est important pour certains
un certain nombre d'entre vous nous
avons besoin de construire une industrie
plus économe en ressources notre projet
de loi vise donc à développer l'usage de
matière première recyclées dans
l'industrie en facilitant la sortie de
statut de déchets il sécurise d'une part
le cadre légal de la sortie de statut de
déchet dite implicite dans les cas où le
déchet vient remplacer une matière
première vierge sans modification du
produit final il ouvre la possibilité de
recycler sans procédure particulière les
résidus de production au sein des
plateformes industrielles si ces résidus
ne présentent pas d'incidences globale
nocives pour l'environnement et pour la
santé humaine ça va sans dire évidemment
ça va mieux en le disant cela favorisera
les pratiques d'écologie industrielles
et territoriales au sein de ces
plateformes
par ailleurs le texte met en place des
amendes administratives contre le
transfert illicite des déchets en dehors
du territoire national ce qui permettra
d'éviter les dépôts sauvages dans des
pays où les contrôles sont parfois
insuffisants et d'apporter une
valorisation et un traitement favorisé
des déchets sur notre territoire
quatrième élément essentiel évidemment
le foncier la rapidité la simplicité des
procédures une économie ressources
économe en ressources le capital
l'argent dans une période contrainte sur
le plan budgétaire nous voulons mieux
mobiliser l'épargne privée
nous mettons donc en place un plan
épargne à venir climat il sera
disponible pour tous les mineurs bloquer
jusqu'à leur majorité avec un taux de
rémunération qui devrait être supérieur
à terme au livret A et un régime fiscal
extrêmement incitatif 0 impôts zéro
cotisation nous attendons de ce nouveau
produit un milliard de collecte un
milliard de financement pour l'industrie
verte et pourquoi pas un peu plus encore
mais aussi un milliard de produits
financiers pour nos jeunes qui en
profiteront pour contribuer avec sans
doute l'argent de leurs parents ou de
leurs grands-parents au développement de
l'industrie verte mais à développer une
connaissance des produits d'épargne
financière
nous souhaitons aussi que le plan
d'épargne retraite
instaurer par la loi pacte et
l'assurance vie plus généralement est au
moins une unité de compte consacrée aux
investissements verts au total c'est 5
milliards d'épargne privé en plus que
nous envisageons d'avoir grâce à ce
projet de loi pour le financement de
l'industrie verte
enfin et nous aurons vous aurez
l'occasion de discuter toute ça dans le
cadre du projet de loi de finance 2024
mais il était important de le mentionner
dès aujourd'hui nous serons le premier
pays en Europe à mettre en place un
crédit d'impôt pour la production
industrielle verte
l'intégralité de ce crédit d'impôt sera
financé par la réduction de niche
fiscale sur les énergies fossiles
conformément à notre stratégie pardon de
bascule une fiscalité brune faire une
fiscalité verte
cinquième élément il est essentiel c'est
celui de la protection une fois que les
usines vertes sont lancées il est
indispensable de pouvoir protéger leur
production nous mettrons en place par
décret un nouveau label excellence
environnemental européenne dit triple
rang tripleux pardon qui valorisera les
entreprises les plus vertueuses avec
notamment un accès privilégié à la
commande publique qui représente au
total près de 150 milliards d'euros par
an
nous voulons transformer en profondeur
la culture des acheteurs publics vous
les connaissez ils sont souvent trop
souvent insécurisés
à acheter des produits qui sont
environnants environ totalement pardon
bien produit qui sont de ce fait très
souvent d'ailleurs produits près de chez
nous c'est l'objet des mesures de ce
projet de loi en faveur d'une commande
publique plus responsable qui favorise
les entreprises plus vertueuses je
précise également que nous modifierons
c'est important les critères du bonus
électrique pour exclure les véhicules
électriques à faible performance
environnementales souvent venu d'Asie le
Bono c'est automobile vous le savez vous
l'avez voté c'est un milliard deux de
subventions à l'achat de véhicules
propres donc aujourd'hui un tiers
partent au bout du monde pour financer
la production de véhicules produits en
Asie il est essentiel que nous puissions
favoriser les productions européennes
dans ce processus d'autres le font aux
États-Unis et en Chine nous devons
également le faire
nous voulons même si ce n'est pas
explicitement présent dans ce projet de
loi je souhaite insister là dessus parce
que c'est un des piliers de la
réindustrialisation les industriels de
vos circonscriptions vous en parlent
tous les jours j'en suis sûr renforcer
la formation renforcer la qualification
vous le savez depuis 2017 le président
de la République les gouvernements et la
majorité sont pleinement mobilisés en
matière de formation et d'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes nous défendrons
plusieurs mesures sur ce sujet dans les
mois qui viennent au-delà des réformes
des lycées professionnels et la
poursuite de l'aide à l'apprentissage en
ce qui nous concerne nous plaiderons et
nous mettrons en œuvre l'augmentation de
22% des places dans les Écoles des Mines
et des télécoms à horizon 2027 nous
mettrons aussi en homme la création de
centre école de production toujours à
horizon 2027 des écoles qui permettent
d'attirer des jeunes qualifiés ou pas
qualifiés du tout vers les métiers de
l'industrie qui les forment qui leur
trouve des jobs ces écoles sont des
exemples à suivre nous devons en
produire davantage mesdames et messieurs
les députés nous souhaitons faire tout
ça évidemment avec l'appui des
parlementaires
vous le savez ce projet de loi c'est une
méthode il a été préparé avec un certain
nombre d'entre vous des élus locaux des
chefs d'entreprise qui ont réalisé près
de 300 consultations nous avons par
ailleurs avec Bruno Le Maire vous le
savez échanger avec la totalité des
groupes parlementaires en amont de
l'examen de ce texte pour améliorer
encore et toujours notre copie nous
sommes évidemment prêts à continuer à le
faire dans le cadre de cet examen
je voudrais d'ailleurs profiter de cette
occasion pour remercier les membres de
cette commission spéciale qui sont
présents depuis le début de la
construction de ce projet de loi
monsieur le président Bruno lemienne
monsieur le rapporteur général Guillaume
kazvariian ben oui il est aussi
rapporteur général il n'est pas
seulement président et les rapporteurs
Marie Agnès poussiévin Spaak Damien Adam
je remercie aussi Astrid Panossian et
Mathieu Lefebvre tous deux pilotes de la
consultation et tous ceux qui nous
rejoignent aujourd'hui et dans les jours
qui viennent au service de notre
économie et de l'école logis le mois
dernier vous l'avez vu le Sénat à
enrichi le texte je pense notamment aux
modalités précises du Plan d'Épargne à
venir climat
en arrivant à l'Assemblée nationale je
sais que deux débats importants sont
toujours en cours et vont sans doute
nous occuper parmi tant d'autres d'abord
le fameux âne le zéro artificialisation
nette la proposition de loi adoptée à
l'unanimité par les deux Chambres du
Parlement je comprends qu'elle sera
discutée en CMP dès le jeudi suis-je
juillet je ne doute donc pas qu'un
accord sera trouvé du coup nos débats
sur ce sujet seront sans doute
extrêmement limités concernant l'article
9 du projet de loi ensuite qui porte sur
l'association des élus locaux à
l'implantation d'un projet national
d'intérêt majeur le Sénat a fait part au
gouvernement de Sa volonté de mieux
associer les élus locaux je partage nous
partageons cette ambition nous savons
qu'un amendement soutenu par
l'Association des maires de France a été
déposé notamment par le rapporteur
général Guillaume Kasparian je tiens à
vous dire d'ores et déjà qu'il a le
soutien du gouvernement
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
conclurai enfin
je conclurai enfin en vous rappelant que
ce projet doit selon nous porte un enjeu
d'union nationale
je ne doute pas que nous dégagerons un
consensus en tout cas nous allons tout
faire pour les postures n'ont pas leur
place quand il s'agit de renforcer notre
souveraineté de réduire les émissions à
hauteur de plus de 40 millions de tonnes
de gaz à effet de serre d'ici 2030 de
moderniser notre industrie de créer des
dizaines de milliers d'emplois bien
rémunérés avec des effets qui vont bien
au-delà et dans tous nos territoires
chaque emploi industriel vous le savez
créez deux ou trois emplois indirects
supplémentaires quand une usine
s'implante quelque part c'est tout le
territoire qui revit ce sont des écoles
des sous-traitants des commerces des
services publics publics pardon et avec
eux du lien social
le Mirail à Toulouse Valenciennes
Montbéliard Flins Aulnay-sous-Bois
dépend entier de nos villes se sont
construits par et pour l'industrie
nous avons vu ces derniers jours avec
des incidents qui n'ont pas épargné nos
villes petites et moyennes combien nous
avions besoin de retrouver cette fierté
de retrouver cette cohésion ce sens de
la contribution bien commun je suis
certain que l'industrie réalisation
verte peut y apporter sa contribution
l'industrie doit et va jouer son rôle
pour donner des perspectives à notre
jeunesse de l'emploi et de l'espoir
produire en France est une évidence
économique sociale écologique nous en
ferons bientôt ensemble une option
concrète attractive et immédiate
c'est-à-dire incontournable je vous
remercie monsieur le président
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre je
passe la parole à Monsieur Guillaume
kasbariian rapporteur général de la
commission spéciale
merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président cher
Bruno monsieur le ministre cher Roland
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
Christine Marie Agnès Anne-Laure et
Damien chers collègues après avoir œuvré
à accélérer
faut pas me couper
en général et censuré je peux merci
beaucoup président après avoir œuvré à
accélérer la production d'énergie
décarbonée à travers deux projets de loi
nous attaquons aujourd'hui une troisième
étape cruciale pour atteindre nos
objectifs de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et accélérer la
décarbonation de notre industrie cet
objectif est un immense défi mais aussi
une formidable opportunité économique et
stratégique pour accélérer le processus
de réindustrialisation dans lequel la
France est engagée depuis 2017 car oui
chers collègues je crois profondément
que l'industrie permet de réconcilier
économie et écologie l'industrie
monsieur le ministre vous le dites
régulièrement d'ailleurs c'est 20% de
nos émissions mais c'est surtout 100%
des solutions aux partisan de la
décroissance à ceux qui considèrent
qu'il faudrait moins de production et
donc moins d'usines et moins d'emplois
industriels dans notre pays je répondrai
que c'est au contraire par l'innovation
par l'investissement par la production
dans notre pays que nous réussirons
répondre à l'urgence climatique notre
modèle français ne doit pas consister à
importer tout ce que nous consommons en
faisant marcher des usines à des
milliers de kilomètres avec de l'énergie
carbonée notre modèle français doit être
celui de la décarbonation de
l'indépendance et de la fierté
industrielle le travail que nous menons
aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans la continuité
des réformes d'attractivité et de
compétitivité mise en place par le
Président de la République et la
majorité en faveur de la
réindustrialisation du pays et après des
décennies de désindustrialisation nous
commençons à voir les premiers résultats
de cette politique depuis 2017 notre
pays a créé plus de 90 000 emplois
industriels ouverts plus d'usines que
déplorées de fermeture la France est
désormais le pays le plus attractif
d'Europe en matière d'investissement
étrangers et je crois que nous devrions
tous nous en réjouir collectivement mais
face à la concurrence mondiale nous ne
devons pas nous arrêter en si bon chemin
il nous faut accélérer et c'est tout le
sens du projet de loi industrie verte
qui vise trois objectifs d'abord celui
d'accélérer l'implantation et le
développement de ces industriels ensuite
favoriser les entreprises vertueuses
dans la commande publique et enfin
financer la décarbonation de notre
industrie avant de revenir sur le fond
de ce texte je souhaite saluer et
rappeler la méthode avec laquelle il a
été construit dès le mois de janvier
Bruno Le Maire et Roland Lescure ont
lancé des concertations pour élaborer ce
projet de loi avec 5 binômes de
coordinateur dont certains sont ici
présents et que je salue nous avons mené
plus de 300 auditions et analyser plus
de 150 contributions écrites
parlementaire élu locaux dirigeants
d'entreprise et représentants de la
société civile on contribué à faire
émerger 29 propositions dont un certain
nombre ont été reprises dans le présent
projet de loi alors je sais que certains
députés regrettent l'absence de mesures
relatives à la fiscalité ainsi que
l'absence de disposition consacrée à la
formation et je tiens à rassurer les
principaux intéressés ces sujets ne sont
nullement laissés de côté ils sont
abordés dans le cadre de disposition
législatives ou réglementaires à venir
j'en profite également pour remercier
chaleureusement Virginie dubismillard et
Philippe bolo ainsi que les
représentants des 10 groupes de
l'Assemblée nationale qui ont participé
aux travaux du groupe de suivi relatifs
à la préparation du projet de loi ainsi
que chacun des rapporteurs thématiques
de la commission spéciale et notre
président pour l'excellent travail mené
ces derniers jours dans des délais
contraints nous pouvons nous réjouir
collectivement d'avoir fait atterrir ce
texte dans les meilleures conditions
j'en viens à présent aux deux chapitres
que je rapporte à savoir le chapitre 1
sur la planification industrielle et le
chapitre 5 qui doit permettre de
faciliter et d'accélérer l'implantation
d'industrie verte je laisserai le soin
aux autres rapporteurs thématiques
d'entrer dans le détail des autres
dispositions de ce texte
l'article premier inclut des objectifs
de développement industriel dans le
stradet la permettra d'identifier plus
facilement les zones propices à
l'implantation de nouvelles industries à
une maille territoriale suffisamment
importante et cela favorisera
l'implantation de grands projets
industriels sur notre territoire le
chapitre 5 concerne les procédures
applicables au projet industriels
d'optimiser pour les projets les plus
importants l'article 8 ouvre ainsi aux
implantations industrielles vertes
reconnues d'intérêt général la procédure
de déclaration de projets qui permet à
l'état d'adapter directement les
documents de planification territoriales
compliquant leur réalisation l'article 9
s'attacha accélérer plusieurs étapes du
traitement administratif des projets
reconnus d'intérêt national majeurs pour
la transition écologique ou la
souveraineté nationale l'état pourra en
particulier mettre en comptabilité
compatibilité les documents de
planification et d'urbanisme et délivrer
les autorisations d'urbanisme
nécessaires je proposerai des
amendements visant à revenir sur des
ajouts des suppressions du Sénat qui
contreviennent je crois à notre objectif
d'accélération mais j'entends
l'inquiétude des élus locaux vous l'avez
dit Monsieur le Ministre et je donc
favorable à l'introduction d'un droit
pour les maires de refuser une
implantation sur leur territoire à
condition que ce droit intervienne avant
que toute la procédure soit engagée
l'article 10 permet de reconnaître la
raison impérative d'intérêt publique
majeurs des projets industriels qui font
l'objet d'une dupe et l'article 11
encourage les regroupements de surface
commerciale au sein d'une grande
opération d'urbanisme pour libérer du
foncier au sein des artificialisé en
faveur de nouvelles implantations en
revanche je vous proposerai des
amendements supprimant l'article 9 bis
car il propose une comptabilisation de
l'artificialisation des sols très
différentes de celles que nous avons
adoptées dans la proposition de loizanne
des sénateurs que nous avons étudié que
nous avons voté une très très large
majorité et d'ailleurs dont la CMP est
prévue ce jeudi matin nous espérons tous
qu'elle sera conclusive avant de rendre
le micro j'aimerais vous dire cher
collègue que je suis convaincu que nous
pouvons rassembler sur ce texte
l'ensemble des Français au-delà des
clivages politiques traditionnels et que
nous pouvons arriver ensemble à faire de
notre pays une grande nation
industrielle décarbonée je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur général je
passe la parole à Madame Christine de
cote rapporteur du chapitre 2 du Titre 1
pour 5 minutes c'est à vous madame merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues le chapitre 2 du titre premier
du projet de loi vise à réduire les
délais de procédure tout en renforçant
la participation du public en janvier
2022 Monsieur Laurent Guillot remettait
au gouvernement un rapport intitulé
simplifié et accélérer les implantations
d'activité économique en France ce
rapport mais en évidence le retard de la
France par rapport à ses voisins
européens en ce qui concerne les
délaissels des procédures d'implantation
de ces activités si la durée théorique
des procédures d'autorisation est
globalement comparable autour de 9 mois
les écarts se creusent lorsque l'on
s'intéresse à la durée réelle des
procédures qui atteindraient jusqu'au 17
mois en moyenne en France je rappelle
huit mois en Allemagne
selon l'auteur du rapport c'est délai
s'explique en grande partie par les
délais intercalaires entre les
différentes phases de la procédure
d'autorisation environnementale ces
délais de coordination entre les acteurs
découle du caractère séquentielle de la
procédure en particulier pour
l'organisation de l'enquête publique
partant de ce constat l'article 2 du
projet de loi propose d'accélérer la
procédure de délivrance de
l'autorisation environnementale et de
moderniser la consultation du public cet
article prévoit tout d'abord un
déroulement simultané des phases examens
du dossier de demande d'autorisation
d'une part et de consultation du public
d'autres parts alors que ces deux faces
ont aujourd'hui distinctes et
successives cette mesure permettra de
gagner près de temps de 3 mois une fois
le dossier de demande déposer et même
souvent davantage en évitant les temps
de passage de relais ou de blocage entre
administration
surtout l'article 2 crée une nouvelle
procédure de consultation du public
celui-ci sera désarmé consulté dès le
début de la phase d'examen et pendant
une période de trois mois contre un mois
aujourd'hui en permettant au public de
participer au processus décisionnel en
matière d'environnement dès le début de
la procédure c'est-à-dire lorsque toutes
les options et solutions sont encore
possibles cette nouvelle procédure de
consultation du public permet d'assurer
un meilleur respect de la Charte de
l'environnement en 2004 particulièrement
l'article 7
la nouvelle procédure de consultation
permet aussi d'assurer une plus grande
interactivité et une plus grande
transparence entre le public et le
porteur de projet elle favorise la
possibilité effective pour le public
d'améliorer le projet la loi précise en
outre que le commissaire enquêteur doit
organiser deux réunions publiques au
début et à la fin de la période de
consultation en présence du porteur de
projet je souhaite saluer ici les
apports du Sénat qui ont permis
d'améliorer de préciser cette nouvelle
procédure de consultation du public le
Sénat a ainsi prévu la possibilité de
désigner une commission d'enquête à la
place d'un commissaire enquêteur unique
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui dans le
cadre de la procédure d'enquête publique
pour les projets les plus complexes par
ailleurs afin de ne laisser aucun
citoyen de côté le Sénat inscrit dans la
loi que le public pouvait faire parvenir
ses observations et ses propositions par
voie postale et pas seulement par
courrier électronique la chambre haute a
enfin souhaité maintenir l'obligation
pour le enquêteur de figuré sur une
liste d'aptitudes ce qui est gage de
compétences et d'impartialité j'en viens
maintenant à l'article 3 qui concerne la
phase amont de la procédure
d'autorisation environnementale cet
article permet l'organisation d'un débat
public global ou une concertation
préalable globale pour plusieurs projets
d'aménagement ou d'équipement envisagés
dans les lisons à venir sur un même
territoire délimité homogène il
s'inscrit dans le prolongement de la loi
ASAP d'accélération et de simplification
de l'action publique ce principe est
étendu par l'article 3 à la demande de
la personne publique qui peut être le
préfet ou une collectivité territoriale
ou un établissement public de
coopération intercommunale
l'organisation d'un débat global ou
d'une concertation globale est en effet
pertinente pour les projets envisagés au
sein d'une même zone à forte activité
industrielle comme par exemple les zones
industriaux portuaires je pense en
particulier excusez moi au développement
d'un centre industrielle autour de la
batterie automobile dans le port de
Dunkerque je connais bien la
mutualisation des débats offre une
meilleure visibilité au public sur
l'ensemble des projets en cours dans la
zone je précise néanmoins que le
caractère facultatif de cette
mutualisation est conservée cet article
3 pourra faire l'objet d'ajustement dont
nous aurons l'occasion de débattre n'en
doute pas en commission enfin le
chapitre 2 du titre premier comporte un
nouvel article de BIS ajoutez à
l'initiative du Sénat il prévoit de
mettre en place des délais maximum pour
l'instruction des projets de déploiement
d'énergie renouvelables dans les zones
d'accélération créées par la loi du 10
mars 2023 je proposerai toutefois la
suppression de cet article ces
dispositions relèvent du niveau
réglementaire et pose par ailleurs des
problèmes d'articulation avec le droit
de l'Union européenne en cours de
modification sur le sujet je vous
remercie de votre attention à ne doute
pas seul instant qu'ensemble nous ferons
mieux tout en faisant plus vite pour
industrialiser des carboner nos beaux
territoires et notre pays merci
merci Madame la rapporteur pour les
chapitres 3 et 4 du Titre 1 je passe la
parole à Madame Marie Agnès
poussiévincebak monsieur le ministre
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs chers collègues certains
d'entre vous peuvent peut-être se
demander pourquoi Nelly d'une cité
maritime embarque si vous me permettez
l'expression sur un texte sur
l'industrie verte vivre grandir puis
administrer une ville au passé
industriel et qui comme de nombreuses
villes de taille moyenne se relèvent
plus lentement qu'elles n'a chuté est
une motivation pour trouver des
solutions alors lorsque Bruno Le Maire
et Roland Lescure m'ont demandé de
copiloter un groupe de travail avec mes
collègues Marie-Claude Jaro Ilham Kadri
et François pontet j'ai accepté bien
volontiers et vous remercie de votre
confiance j'en viens maintenant aux
articles pour lesquels je suis
rapporteur dans son chapitre 3 le projet
de loi prévoit des dispositions
permettant d'encourager le développement
de l'économie circulaire en réduisant le
recours
de la de la matière première vierge et
en permettant des réductions d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre en renforçant le
recyclage et la réutilisation l'article
4 prévoit plusieurs mesures parmi
lesquelles la possibilité au sein des
plateformes industrielles d'utiliser des
résidus de production qui sont présumés
être des sous-produits et non des
déchets la clarification du régime de
sortie du statut déchet et la création
d'un régime de sanctions administratives
applicables au transfert transfrontalier
de déchets illégaux l'article 4 à
introduit au Sénat vise instituer des
projets territoriaux de l'industrie
circulaire mon groupe soutenu par le
gouvernement proposera la suppression de
cet article de nombreux documents de
planification sont en effet déjà
élaborés tant sur l'économie circulaire
que sur la politique en faveur des
entreprises en particulier au niveau
régional j'en viens maintenant chapitre
4 avec cette simple question quel est le
point commun entre une usine désaffectée
une ancienne station-service il s'agit
bien de la réhabilitation des friches
les friches peuvent être des
opportunités pour les de construire sur
un sol déjà artificialisé face à la
raréfaction des réserves foncières
disponibles et l'impératif de limitation
de l'artificialisation des sols nous
avons un impératif celui de facilité la
réhabilitation des friches aujourd'hui
le parcours pour remobiliser les sites
en friche et trop complexe nous
proposons plusieurs évolutions pour le
simplifier ainsi à l'article 5 nous
proposons de faciliter les procédures
existantes de cessation d'activité des
ICPE concrètement l'article 5 permettra
de manière facultative l'intervention de
bureau d'études certifiées pour attester
de la mise en sécurité de la
réhabilitation des ICPE pour les
cessations d'activités notifiées avant
le 1er juin 2022 l'article propose
également l'extension du champ des
opérations pouvant être prises en charge
par un tiers demandeur
à l'article 5 bis nous proposons que la
procédure de déclaration d'État
d'abandon manifeste possibilité que peut
utiliser une commune lors de l'abandon
d'un terrain ou d'un bien soit justifié
par le souhait d'une implantation
industrielle à l'article 5 bisa le texte
prévoit une prise en compte des friches
dans les orientations du Scott comme
c'est d'ores et déjà le cas pour le
stradette ou la carte communale
l'article 6 vise à réformer le mécanisme
des garanties financières obligatoires
pour les ICPE les plus polluantes ce
dispositif qui na hélas pas démontré
d'efficacité en disant et qui ne permet
pas au pouvoir public de bénéficier des
financements nécessaires à la mise en
sécurité et à la réhabilitation des
sites industriels concernés a été
rétabli par le Sénat j'ai déposé un
amendement à l'appui de celui du
gouvernement qui le supprime en
contrepartie parce qu'il y en a les
plafonds des sanctions financières
prévues en cas d'exploitation illégale
sont renforcés et même triplés par
rapport à la proposition du texte
initial il est également prévu que les
sommes nécessaire à la réalisation des
travaux prescrits par un arrêté de mise
en demeure soit consignée auprès de la
Caisse des dépôts et consignations enfin
le niveau de privilège décréances n'est
pour assurer la mise en sécurité des
sites a été relevé au sixième rang en
cas de liquidation judiciaire cet
article permet ainsi de sécuriser le
financement des opérations de mise en
sécurité des sites industriels dans les
cas qui le nécessitent tout
particulièrement l'apparition des
friches industrielles polluées dans les
territoires pour ainsi être plus
efficacement limité l'article 7 réforme
les sites naturels de compensation qui
avait été introduit par la loi
biodiversité en 2016 requalifié en site
naturel de restauration et de
renaturation ces nouveaux sites ont
vocation à faciliter la mise en oeuvre
des obligations de compensation des
porteurs de projets portant atteinte à
la biodiversité la mutualisation entre
plusieurs projets ne sera notamment plus
obligatoire les personnes publiques ou
privées mettant en place ces sites
pourront également vendre leurs unités
de restauration et de renaturation à
toute autre personne publique ou privée
en dehors de toute obligation de
compensation j'ai déposé plusieurs
amendements visant à clarifier la
rédaction de ce nouveau dispositif voilà
pour ce qui les articles qui m'ont été
confiés je nous souhaite des débats
riches et apaisés qui nous permettent
collectivement de faire de l'industrie
française un levier de réduction de
notre empreinte carbone je vous remercie
merci Madame la rapporteur pour le titre
de au nom du titre auto et Madame
Anne-Laure Babeau merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre monsieur
le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues
et mes collègues
le projet de loi relatif à l'industrie
verte poursuit l'oeuvre résolue
verte positive résolu que nous avons
engagé en faveur du révertissement de la
commande publique en effet les marchés
publics qui représentent plus de 110
milliards d'euros annuels constituent un
levier massif et incontournable en
faveur de la transition écologique
l'action de notre majorité sur cette
question est constante je pense
notamment à la loi climat et résilience
qui a été adoptée à la fin de la
précédente législature et qui a apporté
des évolutions majeures dans notre droit
de la commande publique et dans le
renforcement de sa dimension écologique
nous sommes aujourd'hui quasiment à
mi-chemin de l'entrée en vigueur de sa
disposition la plus ambitieuse d'ici
l'été 2026 au plus tard 100% des marchés
publics devront intégrer au moins un
critère écologique
à cette échéance il nous reste encore du
travail à accomplir c'est tout l'enjeu
du titre 2 du présent projet de Loire
relatif aux enjeux environnementaux de
la commande publique et de ses articles
12 à 14
l'article 12 habilite le gouvernement à
légiféré par ordonnance pour introduire
un nouveau motif d'exclusion de la
commande publique en cas de non-respect
des obligations de transparence
extra-financière prévue par la directive
CSRD à savoir l'obligation d'établir un
rapport de durabilité il s'agit là d'un
dispositif analogue à celui qui avait
été introduit par la loi climat et
résilience à propos du plan de vigilance
des sociétés cet article jour un rôle
incitatif utile auprès des entreprises
qui souhaitent accéder à la commande
publique
l'article 13 qui occupera à juste titre
une place prédominante dans nos débats
comprend trois mesures principales tout
d'abord il poursuit le renforcement des
schémas de promotion des achats publics
socialement et écologiquement
responsable l'espaceur dont l'important
c'est primordial pour orienter
l'évolution de la commande publique
ensuite il crée un nouveau motif
d'exclusion des marchés publics pour le
non-respect de l'obligation d'établir un
bilan d'émission de gaz à effet de serre
le BGS
enfin il précise comment l'offre
économiquement la plus avantageuse et
déterminée notamment par la prise en
compte du critère environnemental dans
l'attente de l'entrée en vigueur de
l'article 35 de la Loi climat et
résilience pour finir l'article 14 étant
les dispositions de ce même article et
du présent projet de loi aux îles Wallis
et Futuna à la Polynésie française à la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et auteur australes
et Antarctique française
la discussion de ces articles au Sénat
s'est avéré fructueuse je relève
l'adoption de 3 dispositions
additionnelles à initiative du
gouvernement aux articles 12 bis à 12
quaters ils introduisent les exceptions
au droit de la commande publique pour
les activités d'opérateurs de réseau
acteur majeurs de la transition
écologique il préviennent les risques
d'infructuosité des marchés dans un
contexte économique marqué par la reauté
de l'offre par rapport aux besoins
croissants le Sénat a également
introduit un article 13 bis visant à
favoriser le rétrofit dans le
renouvellement annuel des flottes de
véhicules aux acheteurs publics
votre attention particulière je vous
présenterai une série d'amendements qui
sans revenir sur les apports du Sénat
proposeront différents compromis afin de
rendre pleinement opérationnel les
dispositions que j'ai évoquées il
concerneront l'obligation d'établir
d'établir un BG d'abord en rétablissant
le motif d'exclusion facultatif supprimé
au Sénat ensuite en conditionnant le
bénéfice des aides BPI Adam à
l'établissement d'un BG simplifié pour
les PME et enfin en supprimant le délai
de mise en conformité lorsqu'une
entreprise n'a pas respecté son
obligation d'établir ce bilan permettant
de renforcer la puissance dissuasive de
l'amende pour conclure j'observe qu'une
partie importante de nos débats
porteront sur le renforcement de la
prise en compte des critères
environnementaux dans la commande
publique ou sur une définition plus
précise de ceci notamment pour favoriser
les entreprises locales
si les marges de manoeuvre ne sont pas
inexistantes sur ce sujet bien au
contraire j'en veux pour preuve la loi
climat et résilience et le présent au
projet de loi elle demeure néanmoins
limitée je souhaite rappeler des ici que
le droit de l'Union européenne en cadre
par deux directives le droit de la
commande publique et qu'il impose un
certain nombre de principes fondamentaux
dont celui de non discriminations
notamment en matière d'origine
géographique des produits ou des soumis
ou des soumissionnaires
il faut aussi avoir un tête que
l'acheteur reste libre de définir les
critères qui mobilisent et qu'une telle
définition au niveau de la loi peut
s'avérer veine dans la mesure où les
critères utilisés doivent être en lien
direct avec l'objet de chaque marché
malgré ces contraintes je suis
convaincue que le texte tel qu'il est et
accompagné des amendements que je vous
propose est ambitieux il est injuste
équilibre entre les avancées nécessaires
à la transition écologique et la
capacité des acheteurs publics et des
entreprises à absorber de nouvelles
contraintes de fait je ne doute pas que
nos discussions seront constructives et
permettront de tendre vers un seul
objectif le verdissement de la commande
publique je vous remercie
merci Madame la rapporteur pour le titre
3 monsieur Damien Adam merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues face aux investissements
considérables que nécessitent la
transition écologique la France dispose
de deux atouts une épargne privée
considérable et un secteur financier
solide pour donner quelques chiffres le
rapport Pisani mafuz estime que 66
milliards d'euros d'argent privé et
public seront nécessaires chaque année
pour atteindre les objectifs climatiques
que nous nous sommes fixés à l'échelle
européenne pour 2030 si ce chiffre peut
donner le tournis le montant de
l'épargne des ménages peut aussi donner
lui le vertige entre les produits
réglementés et les produits de fonds
propres le patrimoine financier des
français a atteint 5600 milliards
d'euros au dernier trimestre de l'année
2022 des avancées importantes ont été
réalisées lors du dernier mandat avec la
loi pour la croissance et la
transformation des entreprises dites loi
pacte pour accélérer le déploiement des
labels et à imposer une prise en compte
des enjeux environnementaux dans les
gestion des sociétés l'épargne française
pourrait notamment avec ces mesures
prises dans la loi pacte être mieux
fléchés vers la transition écologique
certains voudraient aujourd'hui
augmenter la fiscalité qui pèse sur les
Français ou sont des thés encore plus
pour répondre à l'enjeu de financement
de la transition écologique nous pensons
pour notre part pour la majorité
présidentielle que des moyens existent
et qu'il faut les mobiliser davantage
c'est fort de ces constats avec Michel
Polin délégués directeur général de VH
cloud j'ai piloté le chantier financé
l'industrie verte française dans le
cadre de la consultation entamé le 5
janvier le 5 janvier dernier qui a
permis de construire ce projet de loi le
titre 3 de celui-ci dont je suis
rapporteur est directement issu des
concertations que j'ai conduite qui ont
impliqué des représentants du monde
associatif du secteur bancaire et
assurantiel des experts environnementaux
et les services du ministère de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
les mesures que je vous propose
d'adopter nous permettront de franchir
de nouvelles étapes et d'atteindre deux
objectifs développer des champions
français de l'Industrie de la transition
et accompagner toutes les entreprises
françaises dans leur décarbonation pour
cela
nous continuons et accélérons la
politique de labellisation pour laquelle
nous sommes déjà une référence en Europe
en effet le label ISR et le label ESG le
plus populaire d'Europe son encourt est
de 777 milliards d'euros soit 6 fois
plus que le deuxième label de sa
catégorie nous créons également avec ce
projet de loi le Plan d'Épargne à venir
climat qui offrira aux jeunes de notre
pays un produit en adéquation avec leur
engagement sur la transition écologique
ce n'est pas une mince affaire puisque
l'épargne des mineurs s'élève
aujourd'hui à 40 milliards d'euros dans
notre pays nous favorisons
l'investissement dans les
infrastructures les petites et moyennes
entreprises et les entreprises de taille
intermédiaires ce tissu qui nous est
indispensable pour réussir la
décarbonation de notre économie et la
transition écologique en même temps nous
élargissons l'horizon d'investissement
les épargnants français en adaptant les
règles applicables au contrat
d'assurance et au plan d'épargne
retraite les épargnants pourront dans
des conditions protectrices accéder plus
facilement à déplacement au couple
rendement risque attractifs enfin avec
ce projet de loi nous a donc notre droit
pour d'un même coup
renforcer l'attractivité de la place de
Paris et nous préparer au déploiement
des fonds européens d'investissements de
longues durées ce qu'on appelle les
altifs 2.0 ce véhicule souple doit nous
permettre de lever 100 milliards d'euros
à l'horizon 2027 orienté vers un
ensemble précis des metteurs les petites
airs entreprises et les actifs réels
dont les contraintes de financement
obèrent la décarbonation la transition
écologique est une nécessité et avec ce
projet de loi avec toutes les mesures
que vous ont présenté les différents
rapporteurs et les éléments de ce titre
3 sera cela pourra également être pour
notre économie un levier de croissance
majeur je me réjouis donc que nous
puissions avoir ce soir le début de
débat sur ce projet de loi et que nous
puissions avancer pour le bien dans
notre économie et de notre transition
écologique je vous remercie merci
monsieur le rapporteur je vais céder
maintenant la parole au rapporteur
d'acquisition des affaires européennes
Monsieur Charles zidstenstool merci
monsieur le Président c'était parfait
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Rapporteur général
chers collègues la commission des
affaires européennes s'est saisie pour
avis du projet de loi relatif à
l'industrie verte considérant qu'il
existait une évidence dimension
européenne aux intentions qui animent ce
texte ce projet de loi va dans le sens
de ce que doit être l'Europe du 21e
siècle la continent plus souverain sur
le plan économique moins dépendant des
autres innovants dans l'industrie et à
l'avant-garde de la transition
écologique grâce à la reconquête
industrielle entamée en 2017 sous
l'impulsion du Président de la
République la France est en train de
redevenir une grande nation industrielle
ce qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû cesser
d'être et ce que de nombreuses nations
européennes n'ont jamais cessé d'être
affichée par le gouvernement de faire de
la France leader européen de l'industrie
verte mérite d'être salué elle sera la
démonstration que nous pouvons allier
développement économique innovation et
écologie le green futur index classement
et établi par le prestigieux mighty
montre que l'Europe est aujourd'hui
leader mondial de la transition
écologique huit des premiers états du
classement sont européens et parmi les
membres de l'Union européenne citons la
Finlande qui est deuxième le Danemark 4e
la Suède 5e le Pays-Bas 6e la France 9e
l'Espagne dixième alors que les
États-Unis ne se ne sont que 19e la
Chine 27e ce classement montre que
l'ambition écologique européenne est
réelle dans ce projet de loi il faut
saluer l'objectif de raccourcir les
délais d'installation et d'extension des
sites industriels en France comparé à
d'autres pays européens je parle là
notamment comme élu alsacien qui observe
ce qui se passe de l'autre côté du Rhin
nous devons mieux faire paralyser que
nous sommes par la bureaucratie et les
procédures trop longues
l'objectif de ce projet de loi de verdir
la commande publique va aussi dans le
bon sens le droit européen permet
d'introduire des critères
environnementaux dans la passation de
marchés publics assumons de vouloir
énoncer une préférence européenne en la
matière
exclure des acteurs non communautaires
et déjà possible dans le cadre des
marchés de défense de sécurité et
d'opérateurs de réseau une mesure
opérationnelle à court terme
consisterait à étendre le droit de
préférence européenne au contrat public
relatif à l'acquisition de technologie
verte par exemple pour l'installation de
panneaux photovoltaïques sur des
bâtiments publics à long terme pour
protéger efficacement son tissu
industriel son marché unique et sa
monnaie commune ma conviction et que
l'Europe devra se doter d'un bail
européenne actes digne de ce nom autre
mesure de ce paquet industrie verte le
crédit d'impôt investissement Industri
verte qui est une incitation fiscale
simple qui s'appuie sur un dispositif
encouragé par la Commission européenne
la France a joué un rôle moteur dans sa
conception bruxelloise et le premier
pays à notifié
si le ciblage des secteurs éligibles
paraît suffisant à ce stade et pour
rappel ce sont les batteries les
panneaux solaires les éoliennes et les
pompes à chaleur il faut laisser ouverte
la possibilité d'une extension à de
nouvelles technologies à compter de 2025
par exemple
l'encadrement temporaire de crise et de
transition adoptée en mars 2022 pour
aider les États membres à soutenir
directement leur économie pour pallier
les conséquences économiques néfastes de
la guerre en Ukraine mériterait d'être
pérennisé au-delà de la borne du 31
décembre 2025 lui aussi à propos des
pieds les projets importants d'intérêt
européen commun cette véritable avancée
européenne doit être préservée monsieur
le ministre les pieds permettent un
usage intelligent des aides d’état pour
aider à la structuration de filières
industrielles compétitive à l'échelle
mondiale que ce soit sur les batteries
d'hydrogène ou la microélectronique mais
la religion de la concurrence étant ce
qu'elle est dans certains services de la
Commission il faut sans cesse rester
prudent et veiller à ne pas complexifier
davantage des procédures déjà lourdes
pour les entreprises et les États qui
recourent
sur la production d'énergie monsieur le
ministre indispensable à toute industrie
j'appelle aussi le gouvernement à
continuer à relayer à Bruxelles la
nécessité d'inclure le nucléaire dans la
liste des financements pour les
technologies propres pour terminer je
souhaite saisir ce moment pour dire
notre insatisfaction quand à la
proposition de la Commission européenne
sur le dispositif step la chronique de
plateformes des technologies
stratégiques pour l'Europe qui n'est
qu'une parodie de fonte souveraineté
comme là d'ailleurs relevé le groupe
Rignoux au Parlement européen
l'enveloppe de 10 milliards d'euros ne
fait pas le poids face au financement
américain et chinois cette enveloppe
pourrait être doublée à 20 milliards
d'euros dans un premier temps et un fond
de souveraineté à l'échelle de nos
ambitions européennes de vraies figurer
dans la dans le prochain cadre financier
plus réel poste 2027 vous l'avez compris
la commission des affaires européennes
émet un avis plus que favorable à
l'esprit de ce projet de loi et je
remercie le gouvernement le président et
le rapporteur général de porter
vigoureusement ce texte merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup monsieur le rapporteur
Monsieur le Ministre ayant souhaité
faire une réponse globale à la fin de
toutes
les prises de parole je vais donc céder
la parole pour les orateurs de groupe à
Marie le bec pour le groupe Renaissance
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues nous entamons
aujourd'hui les débats sur le projet de
loi relatif à l'industrie verte ce texte
est la traduction concrète de notre
engagement en faveur de la décarbonation
de notre industrie je tiens avant de
partager avec vous quelques
considérations sur les objectifs
poursuivis à saluer la méthode qui a été
proposée par les ministres Bruno Le
Maire et Roland Lescure inspiré de la
loi pacte vous avez fait le choix de
co-construire ce texte avec l'ensemble
des parties prenantes 300 auditions ont
ainsi été conduites par des binômes
chefs d'entreprise et parlementaires qui
aboutissent à un texte équilibré et
réaliste qui répond aux légitime
d'attente et exigences des industriels
des investisseurs mais aussi des élus
locaux et des partenaires sociaux et
associatifs la réindustrialisation de
notre pays est un défi collectif qui
commandait de marquer chacun des acteurs
depuis 2017 nous avons inversé la
tendance de destruction d'emplois
industriels elle a plus d'une politique
économique initiée par le Président de
la République et déployé par les
gouvernements successifs avec l'appui de
la majorité avec un solde de positif de
300-îles et 9 un emploi industriels qui
a été recréé depuis six ans nous avons
rempli la première partie du contrat la
France a renoué avec ses capacités à
produire localement quantitativement et
qualitativement j'en veux pour preuve
les récentes décisions à Dunkerque qui
démontent notre capacité à attirer à
innover et produire en France nous
abordons désormais une nouvelle étape
doublé notre objectif économique d'une
exigence climatique nous voulons en
effet produire davantage sur notre sol
car chaque relocalisation création de
sites contribue à réduire notre impact
aux climatique pour réussir ce pari
ambitieux le projet de loi s'articule
autour de trois exigences facilités
financées favoriser si nous voulons
produire en France nous devons
impérativement nous doter des outils
juridiques techniques et financiers
facilitant les créations de sites
industriels car nous souffrons encore
d'un écart de compétitivité par rapport
à nos partenaires européens nous devons
donc accélérer les procédures en ne
renonçant jamais à la protection de
l'environnement ou à la consultation du
public nous devons investir dans les
friches pour les reconvertir en lieu de
production ou encore améliorer le
dispositif site clé en main qui a connu
un réel succès mais qui demande à être
encore plus performant nous devons par
ailleurs soutenir les entreprises les
plus vertueuses grâce à une commande
publique plus responsable car mue par de
nouvelles exigences environnementales
climatiques et sociales avec ce projet
de loi nous modifions donc la commande
le code de la commande publique afin
d'accompagner les acheteurs dans
l'intégration des critères
environnementaux lors de l'attribution
des marchés et des concessions enfin en
complément des actions visant une
meilleure orientation des soutiens
publics le projet de loi en temps
mobiliser l'épargne privé en faveur du
verdissement de notre économie et
singulièrement de nos industries le
besoin en financement seront massifs et
l'épargne doit être orientée vers des
industries vertes depuis six ans nous
avons posé les premiers jalons de cette
politique le plan France relance le plan
France 2030 les lois sur le nucléaire ou
encore les énergies renouvelables ont
permis à notre industrie d'amorcer SAMU
et de démontrer sa capacité à produire
de manière décarbonée mais atteindre la
neutralité carbone nécessitera un effort
historique de modernisation et de
transformation en profondeur de notre
industrie l'état y prendra sa part avec
ce projet de loi nous élaborons le cadre
législatif propice à la réussite de ce
nouveau cap de réindustrialisation nous
renforcerons ainsi l'attractivité et la
compétitivité de la France et nous
répondrons à l'ambition du gouvernement
et de sa majorité de placer les enjeux
climatiques au cœur de son action je
vous remercie
merci madame la députée pour le
rassemblement national Alexandre Loubet
pour 3 minutes merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre de
l'Industrie en grande pompe avec le
ministre Bruno Le Maire vous avez
présenté dans les médias à ce projet de
loi sur l'industrie verte comme étant le
bras armé de je vous cite la reconquête
industrielle de la France mais la
montagne accouche d'une souris derrière
vos effets de communication nous nous
retrouvons en réalité à examiner un
texte bureaucratique et sans vision qui
se résume à un saupoudrage de mesurettes
si nous pouvons effectivement saluer
quelques éléments qui vont dans le bon
sens par exemple pour réhabiliter les
friches ou encore pour alléger certains
normes environnementales ce projet de
loi est insuffisant et il rate sa cible
monsieur le ministre ce texte aurait pu
permettre de créer de l'emploi tout en
réduisant nos émissions de gaz à effet
de serre
mais vous préférez nous le déplorons
limiter l'industrie verte au
développement d'une poignée de
technologie comme les éoliennes le
photovoltaïque ou encore les pompes à
chaleur en effet vous ratez à travers ce
texte l'occasion de soutenir massivement
massivement la décarbonation de
l'industrie française existante tous
secteurs confondus et surtout alors que
la moitié de l'empreinte carbone de la
France est liée à nos importations et
bien vous refusez de mener une politique
de réindustrialisation globale pour
relocaliser un maximum d'activités et
d'emplois sur le sol français en
affirmant que votre projet de loi ne
créera que 40 000 emplois d'ici 2030
vous reconnaissez vous-même que ce texte
n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux vous
reconnaissez vous même votre incapacité
à rompre avec 40 ans de
désindustrialisation qui ont conduit à
détruire deux millions et demi d'emplois
à rabaisser la part de française à 9% du
PIB selon la Banque mondiale ou encore à
creuser notre déficit commercial à plus
de 160 milliards d'euros monsieur le
ministre nous n'aurons pas avec 40 ans
de désindustrialisation sans arrêter de
subventionner nos délocalisations avec
l'argent du contribuable sans mener une
stratégie nationale qui développe des
filières de substitution aux
importations pour réduire nos
dépendances sans appliquer une politique
de patriotisme économique et notamment
dans la commande publique sans protéger
nos TPE et PME de la concurrence
déloyale sans améliorer la compétitivité
de notre industrie notamment en termes
de coût de l'énergie ou encore sans
développer des compétences sur le sol
français ces propositions nous les avons
faites à travers les 215 amendements des
députés du rassemblement national mais
près d'un quart de ses amendements ont
été malheureusement arbitrairement
rejeté nous empêchant de les défendre
à ce mépris du droit dans mon domaine
qui a une valeur constitutionnelle
s'ajoute l'examen de ce texte en urgence
en plein mois de juillet sans aucune
justification valable sur le fond comme
sur la forme vous démontrez donc
monsieur le ministre que ce projet de
loi est bien loin des belles attentions
que vous annonciez à savoir s'enrichir
des propositions des différents courants
politiques et surtout réindustrialiser
le pays je vous remercie merci monsieur
le député pour la France insoumise
madame Alma Dufour monsieur président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
je me souviens lors de la fin du premier
confinement où la France entière avait
été privée pendant des semaines d'un
bien aussi simple mais aussi essentiel
qu'un masque Emmanuel Macron affirmait
qu'il fallait interroger notre modèle de
développement qu'il est des biens et des
services qui doivent être placés en
dehors des lois du marché depuis cette
épiphanie vite oubliée la reprise posz
covid la guerre en Ukraine et
l'inflation historique ont HP de
démontrer que la mondialisation
triomphante des 30 dernières années
derrière nous un flechen réduction Act
aux États-Unis subventions l'énergie en
dessous du coût de production pour les
entreprises en Allemagne marché
européenne l'électricité qui nous
pénalise de façon déconnectée de la
réalité pour cet hiver il est temps que
la France est une réponse à la hauteur
la France est un des pays dont le
déficit commercial est le plus élevé
d'Europe un des pays où la part de
l'industrie dans le PIB a le plus chuté
puisque nous parlons d'industrie verte
la désindustrialisation a provoqué
l'explosion des émissions importées qui
animent les efforts de réduction des gaz
à effet de serre du territoire national
les émissions du secteur industriel qui
pèsent pour 20% non pas bougé les quotas
carbone gratuits ont été un désastre
européen et l'eucanisme le mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières
s'annoncent comme une pantalonnade pour
le climat car il ne couvre qu'une
portion ridicule de ce que nous
importons mais aussi pour la
relocalisation puisque les matières
premières sont taxées mais pas les
produits finis
pour tenir nos objectifs climatiques le
secteur industriel doit réduire ses
émissions de 5% par an un malheur
n'arrivant jamais seul nombre de ces
sites sont vulnérables au changement
climatiques et notamment à l'extension
des zones inondables c'est le cas de
Borealis dans ma circonscription qui se
trouve être le jumeau de l'usine AZF
difficile de relever ces défis quand le
nombre d'entreprises contrôlées par la
puissance publique et passer de 2600 en
1995 à 1800 aujourd'hui cette
privatisation a aggravé les
délocalisations nous sommes passés de
1,5 millions d'emplois un 560 000 dans
ces entreprises celle qui reste nous
font du chantage à la subvention
publique pourtant déversée par dizaines
de milliards avec le plan de relance
sans contrepartie sociale ou
environnementale l'entreprise Parra
petrolière Vallourec à Déville-lès-Rouen
en étant brillante exemple après avoir
été sauvé par la BPI pendant le covid
elle a fermé juste après le site et
détruit au total 380 emplois mais ce
n'est pas parce qu'on s'est trompé 10
fois qu'on ne peut pas recommencer vous
avez décidé de supprimer 16 milliards
d'impôts de production par an là encore
sans aucune contrepartie
produire en France ça doit être une
évidence comme vous l'avez dit Monsieur
le Ministre la crise de l'énergie a fait
exploser les faillites de PME
industrielle menaçant 117000 emplois
dans notre pays derrière les annonces de
gigafactory sud sur Dunkerque même le
secteur automobile continue en réalité
sa sortie de route on est passé de 300
000 emplois en 2000 à 190000 en 2020
dans le secteur 70 000 emplois sont en
danger d'ici 6 ans les usines Renault de
Cléon de Flins sont régulièrement au
chômage partiel payé par l'état car les
voitures électriques ne se vendent pas
aucun infléchissement de la stratégie
des constructeurs vers des véhicules
plus légers pour réussir les normes
défis de la décarbonation et aussi plus
abordables émissions apportées colossale
déficit commercial dans le décor pénurie
de médicaments secteur économique en
roue secteur automobile en roue libre
117000 emplois menacés des sites ces
vaisseaux seuil haut en zone inondables
autant de sujets dont nous devrions
discuter dès maintenant ainsi qu'elles
ne fut pas notre surprise quand nous
avons découvert les trois tests du
projet de loi industrie verte votre
texte est si vite que nous ne pouvons
même pas la demander avec des
propositions qui émanent des
travailleurs des industries ou des
associations de riverains avec ce projet
de loi la seule chose que vous allez
rendre vers ce sont les salariés des
industries qui l'ont toujours aucune
réponse sur l'avenir de leurs emplois
merci madame la députée je vous
demanderai de respecter les temps de
parole merci pour le groupe les
républicains madame Virginie dubulaire
monsieur le Président je commencerai par
remercier la présentation qui a été
faite par le rapporteur spécial et les
rapporteurs pour avis malgré des délais
très courts je vous remercie également
monsieur le ministre pour votre
présentation de ce texte que vous avez
indiqué que c'était un tournant pour
notre économie en effet nous constatons
comme vous une érosion importante de
notre secteur industriel qui s'est
traduite depuis plus de 40 ans par une
perte de 2,5 millions d'emplois
industriels liés à des délocalisations
et à des ventes d'actifs à des groupes
étrangers pendant des années finalement
nous avons assisté à une tertiarisation
de notre économie justifiée par une
mondialisation effrénée au nom d'une
baisse des coûts des biens de production
aujourd'hui la part de l'industrie
française du PIB et de 11% compte
quasiment le double en Allemagne et en
Italie et que par ailleurs l'industrie
représente 19% des gaz à effet de serre
donc il aura fallu finalement des crises
successives pour revenir d'abord à une
notion de patriotisme industrielle et
désormais de souveraineté d'abord sur
les questions alimentaires et médicales
et désormais sur notre industrie qui est
évidemment important avec des enjeux sur
la dépendance envers nos matières
premières
alors ce texte que vous présentez
aujourd'hui comprend des avancées
positives pour enrayer ce phénomène de
des industrialisation massives avec des
ambitions notamment de verdissements il
y a d'abord les mesures de libération du
foncier qui vont dans le bon sens avec
des baisses d'installation pour les pour
les délais pour les entreprises avec la
parallélisation des procédures la
question également des friches
industrielles polluées qui va dans le
bon sens et évidemment il faudra bien
articuler cela en cohérence avec le
texte sur le zan sur la question de la
définition de l'industrie verte vous
l'avez rappelé elle se limite au Big
Five mais et au giga Factory et
finalement pourquoi ne pas l'élargir
c'est une question que nous nous étions
posés avec Philippe bolo sur le groupe
du suivi que nous avons conduit en amont
de l'examen de ce texte le fait aussi
bien sûr de privilégier une commande
publique responsable qui tient compte
des critères environnementaux lors des
choix des fournisseurs va également dans
le bon sens je tiens également à saluer
la méthode qui a été la d'autres très en
amont du texte visant associé à la fois
des élus et des entreprises sur le
modèle de ce qui s'est fait sur la loi
pacte mais je tiens néanmoins à rappeler
qu'il y a un certain nombre de trous
entre guillemets dans la raquette avec
des choses qui n'y sont pas d'abord les
questions de formation d'innovation et
de financement vous l'avez justifié mais
finalement on regrette qu'il n'y ait pas
un débat d'ensemble sur ces enjeux-là il
n'y a pas d'estimation non plus de la
consommation énergétique future qui
apparaît pourtant comme un préalable
essentiel sur cette réindustrialisation
il y a également la question du coût du
travail qui n'est pas évoquée la
question aussi finalement des
importations car ce sont elles
finalement majoritairement qui pèse dans
l'empreinte carbone de notre pays à
hauteur de 51%. on a aussi la question
des contrats long terme pour l'énergie
la question des égards de compétitivité
donc nous avons comme vous le voyez un
certain nombre de points de vigilance et
nous serons vigilants au moment de
l'examen de ce texte merci
merci Madame la député pour le groupe
démocrate et apparenté Monsieur Frédéric
zzinski merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur général Mesdames et Messieurs
les rapporteurs chers collègues après
plusieurs mois de concertation nous
voici réunis pour examiner le projet de
loi quiactera et qui renforcera la
nouvelle trajectoire prise par nos
industries depuis quelques années
maintenant en effet si les chiffres sont
éloquents quant à notre
désindustrialisation depuis le début des
années 70 la situation se débloque en
témoigne l'ouverture de 300 usines et la
création de 90 000 emplois industriels
net notamment grâce aux baisses d'impôts
sur les sociétés et de production des
investissements des plans France relance
et France 2030 mais aussi bien sûr à
l'engagement de nos industriels dont les
attentes sont nombreuses à notre égard
avec ce texte
ainsi nous ne pouvons pas rester les
bras croisés lorsque les procédures pour
l'implantation d'une nouvelle usine sont
quasiment deux fois plus longues que
chez nos voisins allemands lorsqu'un
industriel veut s'installer en France
mais que le foncier manque ou lorsque
nos PME veulent prendre le virage de la
transition mais que l'accompagnement
nécessaire n'est pas suffisant
mais surtout au-delà de l'impact
économique cette réindustrialisation de
notre pays permettrait d'éviter des
millions de tonnes de CO2 par rapport à
un scénario sans changement majeur notre
planète ne peut pas se passer de cette
économie ce texte porte cette double
exigence produire en France et produire
propre pour la réussite de ce projet le
groupe démocrate sera particulièrement
attentif à ce que l'ensemble des sites
soient pris en compte par ce texte
attention à ne pas se concentrer
uniquement sur les futurs installations
mais également aux enjeux de transition
des structures industrielles existantes
sur notre territoire nous serons
également forces de proposition pour
simplifier nos procédures tout en
préservant nos exigences
environnementales en précisant les
conditions de réutilisation d'un résidu
de production par exemple mais aussi en
proposant d'intégrer la gestion de la
ressource en eau au sein de nos
documents d'urbanisme ou encore en
proposant l'interdiction de consultation
publique au mois d'août des dispositions
de bon sens nous semble-t-il qui vous
permettront d'engager l'ensemble des
acteurs dans cette transition nous
soutiendrons également la suppression
des dispositions relatives aux ânes sur
lesquelles notre assemblée vient de se
positionner et dont la CMP a lieu ce
jeudi évitons nous cette répétition et
concentre-nous sur les mesures cœur de
ce texte parmi celles-ci la création
d'un plan épargne à venir climat pour
les mineurs ou encore toutes les mesures
d'obligation de référencement des actifs
non cotés et des fonds labellisés il y a
6000 milliards d'euros d'épargne privé
en France mobilisant l'un avec
efficacité et pragmatisme ainsi le
groupe démocrate se réjouit des débats à
venir et nous serons au rendez-vous des
enjeux pour notre planète pour notre
souveraineté pour notre croissance pour
notre modèle social et pour nos emplois
je vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur
le député pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés monsieur Gérard le seul
ça devrait marcher merci merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre cher
collègue vous avez mené monsieur le
ministre à grand renfort de
communication des consultations lors du
premier trimestre avec des députés de
votre majorité des chefs d'entreprise
pour dessiner un renouvellement
industriel dans notre pays qui souffre
depuis 40 ans d'une forte
désindustrialisation il ne s'agit pas
uniquement de PIB de balance commerciale
mais de milliers d'emplois disparus dans
nos territoires alors
le titre du présent projet de loi
prétend y répondre mais cache en réalité
un texte très peu ambitieux le renouveau
industriel ne peut se limiter à des
slogans sur le verdissement de la
décarbonation de nos industries
sur pardon sur le verdissement de notre
titre production de nous peinons avoir
clairement la traduction ou la
définition de l'industrie verte dans
votre projet de loi l'ambition les
questions liées à la formation
financement de la décarbonation des
industries et aux aides en faveur de
constructeurs automobiles nationaux
initialement présenté en Conseil des
ministres on forme malheureusement toute
disparu tout comme le label 3e dont la
définition est elle aussi repoussée
alors que vous venez une nouvelle fois
d'insister sur ces points importants
votre vision libérale de l'industrie
tchuss France vise finalement à
encourager voire à privilégier des
investissements étrangers sur le sol
national en contrepartie de cadeaux
fiscaux voire de réduction de vigilance
environnementales la principale ambition
de votre sexe vous l'avez rappelé
consiste à diviser par deux le délai
administratif d'autorisation pour
implanter une usine concept c'est
douables mais il conviendrait dans mieux
apprécier les risques de respecter les
précautions environnementales et les
concertations publiques qu'il s'agisse
du développement d'une PME ou d'une
usine de batterie chinoise dont nous ne
maîtrisons ni la chaîne de valeur ni la
maîtrise des brevets nous ne pouvons
traiter tous les projets de la même
manière et nous devrions absolument
privilégié notre souveraineté
industrielle nous considérons donc que
tous les projets industriels ne se
valent pas qu'il faut fixer des
priorités orienter la production vers la
maîtrise des biens matériels dont les
procédés permettent de satisfaire à nos
objectifs de réduction de la
consommation énergétique de
décarbonation et du réduction de notre
dépendance aux importations de matériaux
stratégiques en clair nous venons des
éoliennes françaises des panneaux
solaires des vélos européens renforcent
nous ferons industriels en matière
d'énergie de mobilité préserver nos PME
technique relocaliser les médicaments
essentiels et réellement poser des
enjeux d'une réindustrialisation au
service de nos besoins fondamentaux et
pour cela il aurait fallu créer une
véritable
odyssée industrielle l'inscrire dans une
logique européenne avec la mise en place
d'un mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières adopté à l'échelle européenne
mais décliner aussi à l'échelle
nationale l'examen en première lecture
au Sénat a permis d'ouvrir certaines
portes notamment celles justement d'une
définition d'une stratégie industrielle
grâce à un amendement porté par notre
groupe nous nous en félicitons et nous
aurions souhaité encore renforcé cette
ambition malheureusement l'article 45 a
encore frappé 10 recevabilité nos
propositions de stratégies industrielles
nous sommes bien sûr opposés à l'article
de vis qui prévoit d'exclure du décompte
de zéro artificiel association les
implantations industrielles et enfin
pour terminer sur le champ du
financement nous trouvons là encore
votre texte bien court puisque vous avez
l'ambition de mobiliser 5 milliards
d'épargne sur les 300 millions de
surépargne covid donc nous avons ce
texte avec circonscriptions
circonspection et exigences je vous
remercie vous pouvez aussi l'aborder
avec circonscription monsieur je vous en
voudrai pas
je réserve cela dans un autre territoire
merci pour le groupe horizon monsieur
Alfandari
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs
nous devons produire plus de valeur et
hélas la part de l'industrie a touché
une cote d'alerte en pourcentage du PIB
ça fait longtemps les efforts consentis
depuis quelques années commence à porter
leurs effets nous devons accélérer car
derrière l'industrie c'est l'ensemble
des secteurs d'activités qui seront
entraînés dans une dynamique vertueuse
industrie verte c'est bien sûr des
impacts maîtrisés et raisonnés mais
c'est surtout une décarbonation de notre
société qui est vitale pour notre avenir
grâce à la simplification des procédures
nous relataliserons des activités dont
les produits la mettront pas par leur
transport mais c'est avant tout ne pas
laisser à d'autres et en dehors de notre
regard des responsabilités qui nous
incombent c'est pourquoi le groupe
horizon soutiendra ce projet de loi
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
écologiste Monsieur Charles Fournier
le président monsieur le ministre alors
le sujet aura sans doute du mal à percer
dans une actualité très très chargée et
pourtant nos usines ont façonné hier nos
territoires et nos banlieue et on parle
beaucoup de cela aujourd'hui et la
destrualisation pardon à sans doute
participer à la situation que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui c'est un sujet
qui nous concerne tous comme chef
d'entreprise salariés comme consommateur
comme riverains comme habitants des
territoires alors nous nous en
saisissons pleinement et c'est un sujet
d'importance vous nous proposez à
travers ce texte de produire en France
et de manière décarbonée avec un texte
très technique qui vise finalement à
rapatrier des usines dans notre pays à
réduire l'empreinte carbone vous nous
proposez une loi 0 euros concept
discutable et pourtant l'argent coule à
flot par ailleurs sans contrepartie
j'étais récemment à Grenoble visiter
l'entreprise St microélectronique
2,9 milliards d'euros pose la question
de la contrepartie il n'y en a pas
vraiment
vous voulez produire et vous nous
expliquez que ce texte va contribuer à
transformer l'industrie vous nous direz
d'ailleurs ou dans le texte il y a des
mesures qui participent de la
transformation de l'industrie existante
mais produire sans limite sans
questionner la qualité et la quantité
des produits que nous consommons même
des carbonées ne permet pas de parler
d'une industrie verte une industrie qui
écarte toutes les autres pressions
exercées sur l'eau les sols l'air nos
matières premières ne peut être
qualifiée d'industrie verte une
industrie qui vit seulement à nous
situer dans la compétition
internationale sans se soucier des
limites planétaires qui n'interroge pas
les filières
à accélérer tout comme celles à
transformer voir à arrêter ne peut être
qualifié de verte non une industrie qui
se dessine à Matignon ou à Bercy dans le
modèle serait seulement la gigafactory
ne peut être qualifié de verte non une
industrie qui ne se soucie pas des
hommes et des femmes de leur santé et
par exemple la mise en évidence de la
présence des pifaces dans nos corps dans
nos territoires devraient largement
alerter une industrie qui ne regarderait
pas ce que veut dire le travail à
l'usine dans une France à 50 degrés qui
n'associerait pas les salariés au futur
de leur usine ne seraitent qualifiée de
verte et c'est bien cet écart de vision
qui vous a conduit à analyser la
recevabilité des amendements pardon je
parle fort désolé la recevabilité des
amendements ce sur l'épiface que nous
avions déposé ont tous été rejetés ceux
sur la participation des territoires ont
tous été rejetés ce qui concerne
la l'industrie circulaire ont tous été
rejetés et tant d'autres sujets qui ont
été écartés faisant posant un désaccord
profond sur ce qu'est une industrie
verte alors pour nous une industrie
verte elle repose sur trois piliers elle
doit d'abord être définie et elle doit
être définie sur la base d'une
industrie certes des carbonées mais qui
préserve les ressources qui réduit
l'extractivisme qui fait un usage sobre
des matières premières elle doit reposer
elle doit reposer sur une réelle
réinterrogations de nos besoins au
regard des limites planétaires et enfin
elle doit reposer sur une planification
décentralisée et démocratique alors
c'est sur cette triple ambition que nous
avons déposée tous nos amendements et
nous espérons pour ce qu'il reste que le
débat pourra réellement exister
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
gauche-démocrate et républicaine
monsieur Sébastien Jumel
président
rapporteur ministre
vous faites comme si la casse
industrielle a été une opération du
Saint-Esprit enfin il y a des
responsabilités politiques là-dedans il
y a du renoncement politique là-dedans
il y a la complicité des patrons qui se
sont succédés et qui avaient une vision
court termiste là-dedans les deux
millions de cent mille envois qui ont
été laminés avec les drames humains qui
vont avec avec les humiliations des
salariés qui vont avec avec les
déménagements du territoire dont les
friches sont les cicatrices qui vont
avec avec les pertes de souveraineté que
ça implique sont pas tombés du ciel ils
sont le fruit de renoncement que d'une
certaine manière dans la filiation des
libéraux que vous êtes vous incarnez je
voulais commencer par dire cela alors à
cette situation avec des discours un peu
cocorico vous répondez comme des
libéraux
comme si il s'agissait pour recouvrer de
la souveraineté industrielle de dire les
auto tu les totaux il faut diminuer les
impôts et puis comme s'il suffisait de
simplifier pour que les choses soient
simples en gros votre projet de loi se
limite à silenciennes libérale
rabougri est tellement utilisé dans
d'autres pays avec l'efficacité qu'on
connaît est-ce que les réponses que vous
présentez sont efficaces ou est-ce qu'on
elles sont gazeuses moi je considère
qu'il y a aucune stratégie de
planification comme si le
haut-commissaire à la planification
n'avait pas commis des rapports
intelligents France 2030 est un
dispositif intéressant qui permet
d'accompagner concrètement des boîtes
sauf qu'il ne permet pas de mailler le
territoire avec une logique de
structuration des filières intégrant des
sous-traitants et puis dans une logique
d'aménagement du territoire et puis le
bilan de d'Emmanuel Macron qui se
voulait être le président des startups
nation s'apparente surtout à une
protection des rente
pourtant le groupe communiste considère
qu'il y a des défis majeurs à relever ce
réapproprier notre souveraineté la crise
covid a démontré à quel point c'était
vital pour les médicaments pour les
semis conducteurs et pour tout un tas de
sujets stratégiques pour notre industrie
40% des entrants utilisés en industrie
sont aujourd'hui importés pour
décarboner l'ensemble des filières on
élargissant la responsabilité d'exemples
des grandes entreprises en intégrant les
sous-traitants pour parvenir à recouvrer
une part d'autonomie dans les secteurs
clés énergies industries médicales
industrie agroalimentaire pour lutter
contre les émissions importées en
assumant une forme de protectionnisme il
faut taxer enfin les produits les plus
verts les plus propres bah c'est ce
qu'on importe pas et qui traversent pas
le monde pour venir chez nous dans nos
assiettes dans nos cuisines dans nos
maisons dans nos territoires alors
est-ce que le projet de loi est utile et
ce qui les prometteur ou est-ce que
c'est un texte à énigme et à trous et
bien j'ai peur de dire que rien sur la
conditionnalité
rien sur les prix d'accès l'énergie qui
sont pourtant essentiels à la
compétitivité de l'industrie rien sur la
formation alors vous dites sur tout un
tas de sujets on verra ça plus tard dans
une logique où vous saucissonnez la
politique publique comme si on avait le
temps d'attendre avant de recouvrer de
la souveraineté voilà l'état d'esprit du
groupe communiste à trois voix Hubert vu
le franc Jean-Marc Tellier et jumelle on
va être force de proposition mais on va
être force de proposition non pas
seulement pour faire dire s'il vous
plaît industrie mais pour recouvrer dans
une logique d'aménagement du territoire
et de planification une industrie qui
prend en compte l'intelligence des
salariés s'il vous plaît l'avis des
salariés qui semblent les grands oubliés
de votre projet de loi merci
pour le groupe liotte enfin Monsieur
Benjamin sainte-huile merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
permettez-moi de saluer le propos
équilibré que vous avez tenu en
démarrage de nos travaux vous avez
évoqué un tournant économique majeur la
fin du désastre de la désastronalisation
ou encore par certains aspects un texte
révolutionnaire bon je crois qu'il faut
arrêter les éléments de communication ce
texte il peut être utile nécessaire mais
il faut atterrir il s'agit de travailler
sur des besoins fonciers avec des sites
clés en main il s'agit d'accélérer les
procédures d'urbanisme et d'essayer de
les diviser par deux il s'agit de verdir
l'affaire on va y revenir dans un
instant avec une définition qui est
quand même assez contestable et
discutable et il s'agit d'essayer de
trouver des commencements de début de
financement bon en réalité ce que
personne ne dit ici c'est qu'on a là un
texte qui a vocation à répondre pour
partie à l'IRA américain en précisant
que lira américain
c370 milliards et que donc je serai
intéressé au nom du groupe lot de voir
jusqu'où nous irons en la matière et
l'ambition que celle de la France si je
divise la population pour arriver à
notre ratio j'imagine donc on sera
autour de 70 milliards je ne suis pas
sûr que les comptes seront faits à
l'arrivée je veux dire deux trois choses
sur la méthode parce que je dois dire
que depuis que nous sommes ici une
grosse année je m'étonne toujours
d'utiliser un vocabulaire qui est pas la
réalité vous parlez de concertation non
nous avons été consultés après que les
groupes de la majorité et travailler
pendant un certain temps et on nous a
dit une fois que le texte avait été
présenté en Conseil des ministres est-ce
que ça vous convient bon je faut dire
les choses c'est pas de la concertation
ça c'est de la consultation le texte
vous avez décidé chacun l'a dit avant
moi de le saucissonner ce qui fait qu'on
discute pas de formation pas de la
manière dont on va travailler sur
l'emploi on discutera pas des finances
on a deux trois sujets qui nous
intéressent plus ou moins je dois dire
que de notre point de vue le Plan
d'Épargne à venir climat ne répond en
rien à nos besoins par contre tout ce
qui concerne la contribution minimale à
l'assurance
ou du plan d'épargne retraite peuvent
être des pistes intéressantes mais
objectivement c'est quand même assez
fatigant intellectuellement de se
retrouver dans des moments où on parle
de sujets qui se veulent majeurs et
qu'on les prenne par le petit bout de la
lorgnette de manière générale nous nous
considérons que ce texte il fera
beaucoup de déçu s'il ne va pas au bout
de la logique enfin et pour ne pas être
trop long nous nous disons simplement
que nous nous interrogeons sur la place
des collectivités cela a été dit par les
uns et les autres nous verrons la teneur
des débats en la matière mais
reconnaissons que lorsqu'on imagine des
procédures spécifiques qui permettent au
préfet de squeezer complètement les
genoux local on se met en difficulté
quand on imagine avoir des dérogations
sur la consultation publique ou sur la
mutualisation de la concertation vous
prenez un risque majeur vous voulez
accélérer et vous prenez le risque du
contentieux et comme vous n'avez pas de
prise sur le temps du contentieux à mon
avis on peut produire des effets qui
seront inverses à ce qui est recherché
bref de manière générale le texte il est
plutôt dans le bon sens mais nous ne
regrettons et la méthode et la manière
dont vous construisez des éléments de
langage qui sont très en décalage avec
la réalité opérationnelle du texte je
vous remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
député monsieur le ministre pour des
éléments de réponse au rapporteur et aux
orateurs de groupe
merci monsieur le Président merci à tous
et à toutes je voudrais d'abord
remercier les rapporteurs de la
commission pour leurs interventions qui
montrent d'ores et déjà leur parfaite
maîtrise du texte et les avancées qu'ils
ont avancées et présenté rapidement qui
vont nous permettre je n'en doute pas de
faire avancer le texte encore au-delà de
ce qui a déjà été
obtenu dans les cadres de l'examen au
Sénat je voudrais aussi remercier le
rapporteur spécial pour avis de la
commission de l'affaire européenne le
députés de listenstool pour son
intervention extrêmement importante
effectivement nous ne
réindustrialiserons la France que si on
le fait dans un cadre européen ambitieux
et de ce point de vue là j'ai tendance à
rejoindre un certain nombre de vos
remarques nous avons fait beaucoup pour
faire bouger l'Europe
et contrairement à ce que certains ont
dit ici ou là je pense que la politique
industrielle française est le début de
changement de la politique industrielle
européenne sont toutes sauf libérales on
a renforcé le dispositif d'être d'État
on a soutenu les secteurs et des pas
entiers de l'économie pendant la covid
on a continué à le faire au sortir de la
covid pour relancer dans une bonne
vieille relance canadienne qu'à mon avis
la partie gauche de cette commission ne
devrait pas
refuser et on est aujourd'hui dans une
logique où on est en train de financer
une transition de l'industrie verte j'y
reviendrai pour les questions sur la
conditionnalité de manière au fond assez
conditionnel je rejoins ce que vous
dites sur les avancées européennes liées
aux démarches françaises extrêmement
ambitieuses portées depuis six ans
depuis le discours de la Sorbonne que
j'espère vous avez tous écouté d'accord
ou pas avec des résultats extrêmement
concrets sur l'endettement commun sur
l'évolution du dispositif d'adeta sur la
notion de souveraineté qui n'existait
pas avant la Sorbonne et qui désormais
est intégré dans une politique
industrielle américaine européenne
pardon vous avez parlé du fond souverain
dont vous jugez insuffisant les montants
je veux bien de l'entendre retenons
quand même que ce fond souvent sans le
manuel Macron et sans tirer breton qui
est le commissaire français au niveau de
la Commission européenne Xe il
n'existerait sans doute même pas donc là
aussi faisons mieux continuer à faire
progresser l'Europe vers la voie de la
réindustrialisation mais je pense qu'on
peut tous noter l'apport extrêmement
fort de la France depuis maintenant six
ans au renforcement et à la
transformation en profondeur de la
politique européenne et notamment
évidemment de celle qui m'est cher de la
politique industrielle
merci aux orateurs quand je vous entends
tous et toutes je me rends compte
d'abord que je pense qu'on est quasiment
unanimement d'accord sur les constats et
moi ce qui m'intéresse maintenant
c'est de construire la
désindustrialisation de la France a été
un désastre je sais pas si c'est le
résultat de politique libérale ou pas de
politique libérale je note que
l'Allemagne je note que l'Allemagne qui
est pas moins libéral que nous
qui est pas moins libéral que nous
messieurs les députés à une industrie
qui pèse pour 22% donc deux fois plus
que la France donc c'est peut-être un
peu simple et un peu rapide de dire vous
êtes libéral vous êtes industriel vous
n'êtes pas libéral vous ne l'êtes pas
l'Allemagne est libéral monsieur jumelle
nous vous en déplaise les impôts en
Allemagne sont bien moins inférieurs au
nôtres les aides d'État sont tout aussi
importantes voire même un peu plus par
tête de pipe qu'elles le sont en France
et pour autant ils sont à 22% peu
importe j'allais dire maintenant on est
où on est je pense que j'ai entendu un
consensus sur le fait qu'on est bien à
11% aujourd'hui dans des plaises à
Monsieur Loubet qui mentionne le chiffre
9% l'Insee indépendant et français
devrait vous sourire nous sommes à 11%
d'industrie et l'objectif général de
cette commission devrait être de trouver
les moyens d'aller plus haut
nous avons stabilisé ce niveau depuis 6
ans nous avons certes continué j'ai
entendu madame Dufour le dire avoir des
usines fermées en France et je le
regrette chaque usine qui ferme est une
difficulté importante pour les
territoires mais je pense que vous
reconnaîtrez avec nous j'espère qu'on a
fait deux choses face à ces mouvements
d'abord on a ouvert et réouvert des
usines en France et on ouvre depuis 5
ans plus d'usines qu'on enferme et de
des usines des
usines comme ACC que j'ai inauguré à
Douvrin il y a quelques semaines qui va
fabriquer des centaines de milliers de
batteries dans un territoire qui
historiquement était dans illustrialiser
pour moi c'est une vraie usine on a
parlé de St monsieur Fournier on peut
avoir un débat sur la politique de
gestion de l'eau et je pense que c'est
un sujet intéressant auquel vous vous
intéressez auquel je m'intéresse et
auquel l'entreprise s'intéresse aussi
mais ça va être une très belle usine qui
va créer de l'emploi qui va accroître la
souveraineté de la France sur les
micro-processeurs qui sont depuis des
années construire à l'étranger et donc
moi je m'en félicite et puis la deuxième
chose qu'on a faite parce que je peux
vous dire qu'on le fait tous les jours
au ministère de l'Industrie c'est qu'on
aide et qu'on appuie les industries qui
souffrent on a trouvé un repreneur pour
carlaigle on est aujourd'hui en train de
retrouver en tout cas de tout faire pour
retrouver des repreneurs pour terréos et
pour Caudry on travaille à la reprise
potentielle de valdune donc sur toutes
les entreprises qui ferment
sur toutes les entreprises qui sont en
difficulté aujourd'hui nous avons au
minimum une obligation de moyens pour
les aider à rester là où elles sont et à
continuer à se développer et pour
l'instant les moyens on n'a pas les
idées dessus et les résultats on
commence à en avoir et donc le
volontarisme industriel je pense qu'on
peut nous reprocher beaucoup de choses
mais depuis 6 ans je pense pas qu'on
peut nous faire ce reproche là j'ai
entendu monsieur monsieur Loubet que
vous jugiez ce projet de loi trop étroit
je vous engage vraiment à le relire en
détail à l'occasion des débats au sein
de cette commission n'étiez pas là
Monsieur Tanguy quand il a fait son
intervention moi je l'ai écouté
ah c'est ça alors je vous avais pas vu
je vous avais je vous avais vu arriver
un peu plus tard j'ai dû me tromper
alors mais monsieur non vous n'êtes pas
dans ma tête je vous rassure monsieur
Loubet toutes les dispositions que nous
avons mis dans ce texte pour simplifier
amplifier et accroître les installations
industrielles en France concernent
l'ensemble de l'industrie parce que nous
avons deux convictions très fortes la
première c'est que produire en France
dans la majeure partie des cas ça émet
moins de gaz carbonique de le faire au
bout du monde et que deux nous sommes
convaincus et nous l'accompagnons que
même l'industrie traditionnelle
française est une source de
décarbonation puisqu'elle se décarbonne
aujourd'hui les clients leur demandent
leurs employés leurs demandes leurs
actionnaires nos demandes leur état leur
demande nous avons un mécanisme très
fort d'accompagnant de la
réindustrialisation qui va à la fois je
l'ai dit dans mon introduction permis de
verdir l'industrie traditionnelle et oui
aussi permettre de développer une
industrie verte de qualité en France un
certain nombre d'entre vous et je dois
reconnaître que je suis d'accord avec
vous mon interpellé sur le déficit
commercial bien trop large de la France
il est le résultat de cette
désindustrialisation massives qu'on a
obtenu depuis 25 ans si on veut
renverser cette tendance il va falloir
produire de l'industrie en France
industrie capable de s'exporter donc oui
de l'industrie compétitive de
l'industrie qui va se permettre de se
développer qui va être capable d'aller
gagner des parts de marché dans le monde
et donc une industrie qui va devoir
vivre avec des frontières ouvertes la
science sera peut-être pas tous d'accord
j'ai entendu quelques remarques mais
l'essentiel pour moi évidemment c'est de
Ré industrialiser la France avec une
industrie je le répète compétitive et
verte je suis convaincu qu'on peut faire
les deux oui madame Dufour et je pense
quelques autres m'ont interpellé là
dessus on répond à l'Iran je pense que
c'est aussi le cas de Monsieur
Saint-Huile qui a terminé son
intervention là dessus
et au fond on n'a pas à rougir des
montants France 2030 c'est 54 milliards
France relance c'était 100 milliards on
est bien au-delà d'IRA sur les montants
la réalité la réalité aujourd'hui c'est
quand vous demandez aux industriels
quand vous en demandez aux élus locaux
quand vous demandez j'ai entendu
monsieur jumelle votre interpellation
auprès des salariés moi je suis dans des
usines une deux trois fois par semaine à
chaque fois je me débrouille pour voir
les organisations syndicales et discuter
avec les salariés tous me disent on a
besoin de terrain on a besoin de talent
on a besoin de financement les salariés
nous disent vous nous avez bien aidé
continuez à le faire chez Duralex et
ailleurs aujourd'hui
c'est pas les montants qui nous posent
des problèmes c'est nos procédures c'est
notre capacité à accélérer le mouvement
c'est notre capacité à accélérer le
mouvement monsieur fourni sans baisser
la garde sur l'environnement et vous
verrez que dans ce projet de loi il n'y
a aucune aucune remise en question des
contraintes environnementales aucune on
parallélise des procédures qui existent
déjà on augmente la durée de l'enquête
publique on renforce un certain nombre
de procédures on souhaite évidemment
aller plus vite on souhaite être plus
efficace mais en aucun cas en baissant
la garde sur l'environnement parce qu'on
est convaincu que c'est un des éléments
essentiels de la compétitivité de demain
et donc l'IRA on est au niveau point de
vue des euros je pense pas qu'on soit au
niveau au niveau de la simplicité et de
l'efficacité des procédures des
procédures américaines pardon qui sont
effectivement très efficaces un certain
nombre de vous m'ont interpellé sur les
médicaments
je voudrais quand même le rappeler qu'il
y a maintenant trois semaines en Ardèche
le président de la République annoncé le
rapatriement en France de la production
de 25 médicaments essentiels c'est une
avancée j'espère que vous noterez tous
j'ai entendu madame Dufour là je vais me
permettre de vous corriger dire que
l'industrie n'avait pas baissé ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre entre
1990 et 2021 l'industrie et le secteur
qu'il est à le plus baissé 44% et je
vais vous dire une chose il est très
probable que l'industrie soit encore le
meilleur élève dans les 20 à 30 ans qui
viennent parce que l'industrie au fond
c'est une manière extrêmement efficace
de décarboner les 56 vous connaissez le
site boralis vous m'en avez parlé je
pense qu'il est numéro 25 sur les 50
c'est un des sites les plus émetteurs en
France si on décarbonate Boréalis
on va avoir un triple gain un parce que
Boréalis lui-même dans sa production
n'émettra plus que 50% de gaz à effet de
serre en 2030 et 0 en 2050 2
boréalisme vous le savez produit des
engrais qui eux-mêmes sont moins
carbonées que ceux qu'on importe de
l'étranger et donc on va en profiter je
vais vous laisser me répondre si vous le
souhaitez mais je vais terminer voilà
d'ailleurs c'est le président qui décide
c'est pas moi j'ai pardon je l'ai vu
réflexes excusez-moi monsieur Miss
madame Dufour on n'est pas dans
l'hémicycle pas d'interpellation chacun
prendra la parole si vous voulez poser
une question après vous pourrez le faire
mais vous n'interrompez pas le ministre
en tout cas Boréalis ça va être le
triple effet Kiss Cool un on va
décarboner vos réaliste 2 on va produire
de l'engrais des carbonée par rapport à
ceux qu'on importe aujourd'hui et donc
on va en profiter pour des carbonner une
partie de notre agriculture sans peser
le fardeau sur nos agriculteurs
eux-mêmes et trois on va avoir de
l'engrais compétitif on va pouvoir
exporter et donc contribuer positivement
à la fois au développement de votre
territoire et celui qui est cher
Monsieur Damien adan qui est pas très
loin de chez vous non plus et restaurer
une partie de nos déficits commerciales
donc vraiment là dessus
j'engage tout le monde a bien intégrer
le fait que je sais pas c'est une
montagne je sais pas si c'est une souris
ce texte mais il va dans le bon sens il
crée un certain nombre de changements
fondamentaux dans nos procédures il crée
un changement d'état d'esprit il met au
fond dans un texte ce que je vois moi
tous les jours sur les territoires un
alignement de tous les élus ou presque à
quelques exceptions autour de
l'industrie l'industrie française elle a
pas de couleur de maillot aujourd'hui je
suis chez des maires républicains chez
des députés socialistes chez des
conseillers régionaux écologistes et
évidemment régulièrement dans les
circonscriptions de la majorité à chaque
fois je vois des élus qui sont prêts à
accompagner le développement de leur
industrie monteront aussi dans le cadre
de cet examen que nous pouvons
travailler ensemble pour faire avancer
et tous les secteurs j'ai entendu un
certain nombre d'interpellations sur les
filières moi je travaille tous les jours
avec les comités stratégiques de filière
les filières leur objectif les plantes
filières qu'on est en train de signer
les uns après les autres pour les 5 ans
qui viennent c'est très simple des
carbonnons et des carboneons ensemble je
vous rejoins monsieur jumelles il y a
des filières qui sont insuffisamment
exemplaires sur la gestion des
sous-traitants on travaille avec eux là
dessus il y en a d'autres qui sont
exemplaires et j'espère que vous le
reconnaissez madame dubis Muller vous
m'avez posé un certain nombre de
questions extrêmement pertinentes
notamment sur les enjeux de consommation
énergétique parce que c'est vrai que
pour la décarbonation l'énergie est
notamment l'énergie décarbonée ça va
être le nerf de la guerre je vous engage
juste pour ces questions là à attendre
la loi de programmation énergétique qui
arrivera à l'automne et qui je pense
aura l'occasion de vous apporter toutes
les réponses que vous avez aux réponses
que vous avez aux questions pendant que
vous avez formulé
j'ai eu pas mal de questions notamment
madame bibi Muller mais d'autres sur la
définition de l'industrie verte c'est
aussi une cas je pense du député le seul
on va en parler dans quelques minutes il
y a beaucoup d'amendements sur le titre
et beaucoup d'amendements sur la
définition de l'industrie verte je
voudrais quand même vous dire que
aujourd'hui c'est simple le verre pour
moi ça doit être partout et donc le
risque de définir de manière trop
précise ce qu'on entend par industrie
verte ou ce qu'on entend par
vernissement c'est
de s'empêcher d'un certain nombre de
technologies modernes qui vont nous
permettre de verdir qui n'existe
peut-être pas aujourd'hui ça va nous
empêcher de verdir les aciéries qui sont
toutes sauvés aujourd'hui Arcelor c'est
7% des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
en France mais ça veut dire qu'on peut
en décarbonant harcelor des carbonés 7%
de l'industrie française donc et donc
harceleur à ce décarboner simplifiant
les procédures pour eux et pourtant
d'autres de manière à ce qu'on puisse à
la fois je le répète c'est un enjeu
majeur
verdir l'industrie traditionnelle et
développer l'industrie verte je serai
pas plus long que sur le président
j'espère avoir répondu à l'essentiel des
interpellations on aura évidemment
l'occasion de revenir surtout ça dans le
cadre de l'examen des amendements bien
merci Monsieur Miss nous avons encore un
certain nombre de prises de parole
individuelles je vous rappelle et je
serai assez intransigeant sur le timing
une minute simplement si vous voulez
qu'on commence à aborder le texte ce
soir on a quand même un peu plus de 1000
amendements à
étudier donc une minute par intervenant
je commence par Madame Christelle PETEX
levé pour les républicains
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre député et citoyenne du ciel
d'une circonscription fortement
industrialisée et berceau du delcoltage
je vis aux côtés des industriels ce
projet de loin industriel verte semble à
ce jour réducteur et décevant je me fais
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs leur voix car se
souvient eux les premiers concernés le
zan l'exclusion des projets industriels
concurrents à la transition écologique
ou essentielle pour la souveraineté
nationale est une avancée mais quels
seront les projets réellement concernés
et comment feront tous les autres la
réhabilitation des friches industrielles
est la mise à disposition de terrain
semble une idée louable toutefois quid
des terrains et des territoires s'en
fiche industriels quels seront les
solutions proposées bilan carbone il y a
une vraie inquiétude sur l'exclusion de
la commande publique de toutes les
entreprises ne respectant pas les
obligations tout ton envie simplement
elles ne vont pas à la même vitesse pour
aboutir à leur décarbonation cette règle
va créer d'importants d'inégalités ce
projet de loi va-t-il réellement
permettre la réduction des émissions
apporter de la France soit la moitié de
notre empreinte carbone en franchisant
la commande publique au maximum je vous
remercie merci madame la députée pour le
groupe les républicains madame Émilie
Bonivard merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre une question qui
concerne les industries électro
intensives
elles sont essentielles aujourd'hui
c'est de nos industries lourdes pour
l'essentiel elles sont essentielles dans
la production de bien stratégies qui est
nécessaire à notre indépendance je pense
à l'aluminium à l'acier vous l'avez
mentionné à la chimie aux silicium et il
est essentiel que nous les gardions sur
notre territoire elles font partie
effectivement des industries les plus
émettrices sur lesquelles vous souhaitez
agir toutefois les plantes des
carbonation sont des plans extrêmement
capitalistiques pour elle avec des
durées d'amortissement très longs et
avec une paire de compétitivité sur les
dix années pas nécessaire alors
investissement or que va-t-il se passer
post à Rennes si elles n'ont pas de
visibilité sur le coût de l'énergie
alors qu'elles sont électro-intensives
et que le prix d'énergie rentre dans 30%
de leur coût de production elle ne
pourront pas investir massivement dans
la décarbonation besoin de visibilité
sur le poste à Rennes et le les
dispositifs de contrats merci madame la
députée pour la France insoumise même
Clémence guetter
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre il y a un double problème dans
ce projet de loi le premier problème
c'est ce qu'il contient mais en va
longuement y revenir le deuxième c'est
ce qu'il manque dans ce projet de loi il
n'y a rien pour former les travailleurs
et les travailleuses de l'industrie de
demain que vous promouvez il y a rien
pour anticiper nos besoins en matière de
qualification vous avez ainsi jugé et
recevable beaucoup de nos amendements
dont certains que nous avions déposé
pour anticiper les besoins en matière de
métier de façon à pouvoir penser
l'adaptation de l'offre de formation
vous avez rejeté aussi la création d'un
Conseil national de la qualification
professionnelle qui pouvait permettre de
quantifier ses besoins métiers par
métier première question donc pourquoi
prendre encore une fois les choses à
l'envers pourquoi vous prétendre vouloir
réindustrialiser le pays tout en ne
prévoyant rien à ce stade pour la
formation et le développement des
qualifications utiles pour la
bifurcation industrielle ça aurait sa
place dans la stratégie nationale
industrielle deuxième question les
moyens vous avez parlé de l'augmentation
de 22% des places en école mines et
Telecom ça coûterait environ on un
milliard si on en croit France 2030
pouvez-vous nous donner une évaluation
des moyens nécessaires pour la formation
pour le groupe rassemblement national
Monsieur Nicolas maisonnet merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre on ne comprend pas nous sommes
visiblement nombreux à ne pas comprendre
comment vous pouvez former le vœu d'une
grande loi sur l'industrialisation en ne
traitant pas la question de la main
d'oeuvre à notre temps pas la question
de la formation et on ne comprend pas
d'ailleurs monsieur le Président
pourquoi la totalité de nos amendements
sur cette question ont été rejetées on
est pourtant en plein dans le sujet et
c'est un enjeu essentiel n'importe quel
chef d'entreprise n'importe quel
industriel vous dira qu'une industrie
c'est d'abord des femmes et des hommes
des ressources humaines et vous savez
pertinemment que l'on a un déficit
immense de ce point de vue là et chacun
perçoit les écueils de ce déficit taux
de vacances d'emplois élevé des fautes
compétences recours à crues aux heures
supplémentaires baisse de la
productivité délai de production et de
livraison plus longs au final manque de
compétitivité augmentation des
importations alors Monsieur ministre
comme vous n'avez pas répondu je vous
repose la question comment avez-vous pu
passer à côté de ce volet majeur
merci monsieur le député merci d'avoir
respecté votre temps Monsieur Pierre
Meurin pour le rassemblement national
merci monsieur le Président millienne
puisque il s'agit de d'un sujet
relativement semblable nous sommes dans
une certaine forme d'abîme de perplexité
puisque il me semble que l'article 45 de
la Constitution dispose que les
amendements sont recevables quand ils
présentent un lien même indirect avec le
texte or pour donner un petit exemple il
me semble que la responsabilité
environnementale des filières
industrielles présentent un lien avec le
sujet de l'industrie verte donc je
m'offusque de cette arbitraire dans le
traitement de la recevabilité des
amendements je pense que nous sommes
très nombreux à se poser cette question
là je ne vois pas finalement en quoi
vous vous pouvez considérer que ce la
responsabilité environnementale défi
industriel n'est pas de lien avec le
sujet de l'industrie verte le sujet de
la formation est identique par exemple
vous avez accepté un amendement sur les
ZFE qui me semble présenter bien moins
de liens
peut-être que vous avez envie de
débattre de ça parce que c'est aussi
votre sujet et que vous regrettez de pas
être à l'aise avec moi demain si
Monsieur Pierre Meurin je ne serai pas
avec vous demain ne vous en déplaise
pour le rassemblement national Monsieur
Nicolas dragon
merci monsieur le Président cette
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre je monsieur le ministre je
profite de votre présence et de vous
avoir sous la main on est d'accord tous
les pays qui s'en sortent sont ceux qui
possèdent une industrie forte nous le
voyons avec l'exemple du Japon de
l'Allemagne des États-Unis ou encore de
la Chine et la France doit revenir dans
cette position mais j'ai une question un
peu plus départementale je suis élu dans
le département de l'Aisne dans l'Aisne
il y a actuellement un projet
d'implantation d'une usine recoule près
de Soissons c'est pas sur ma
circonscription c'est un projet de 130
emplois 130 millions d'euros
d'investissement qui sera destiné à
produire des produits isolants en laine
de roche destinée principalement au
marché français et la technologie
utilisée sera une technologie de fusion
électrique à faible émission de carbone
et ma question est très simple ce projet
depuis un an
subi de fortes contestations
même de la part d'élus tout autour
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez sur cette
question précise je vous remercie merci
Monsieur dragon pour la France insoumise
monsieur Mathias Tavel
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre votre texte est effectivement
comme beaucoup l'ont dit un texte à trou
on cherche tout ce qu'il y a dedans mais
surtout on cherche tout ce qu'il n'y a
pas dedans on l'espèce depuis
Saint-Nazaire nous voyons pas de
protectionnisme sur la question par
exemple des énergies renouvelables et
des énergies marines renouvelables que
vous semblez ainsi prédestiné à la même
au même avenir que le photovoltaïque
hier rien sur les droits des salariés
pour faire cette bifurcation écologique
comment pensez-vous pouvoir transformer
les entreprises sans les salariés c'est
pourtant plusieurs amendements que nous
avions déposés qui ont été déclarés
irrecevables pour obliger à ce qu'il y
ait des négociations sur cette
bifurcation dans les entreprises pour
créer des droits nouveaux par exemple
pour les CSE à propos de la bifurcation
écologique de l'industrie enfin rien non
plus sur la protection des installations
classées pour l'environnement et des
sites ces vaisseaux pas même la création
d'une autorité indépendante pourtant il
y en aurait besoin si on veut
réindustrialiser en confiance
merci Monsieur Tavel pour le groupe
écologiste Monsieur Charles Fournier oui
merci à travers ce texte on Apple
l'impression que on est dans une
planification par le haut et qu'on va
mettre des usines dans le territoire et
qu'on inventera la vie qui va avec après
juste donner un exemple sur les panneaux
photovoltaïques je vais visiter il y a
pas longtemps l'entreprise Photowatt et
je tire la sonnette d'alarme qui va
peut-être fermer ses portes parce que
par ailleurs on est en train d'inventer
une giga Factory dont on entend parler
mais dont on ne sait pas grand chose au
détriment d'entreprise qui existent dans
notre pays je pense à voltèque du côté
de Strasbourg on pourrait reconstituer
une filière à partir de ceux qui
existent et pas forcément seulement sur
le modèle de la giga Factory alors
comment avez-vous comment allez-vous
associer les territoires toutes les
parties prenantes des territoires pour
réussir cette industrialisation puis
deuxième question je voudrais vous
parler de la question de l'eau des
métaux rares de des pollutions quand on
discute avec St c'est pas juste la
question de l'eau qui est en jeu c'est
aussi l'utilisation des métaux rares
c'est aussi la question des pollutions
et pourquoi pourquoi ne mettez-vous pas
des contreparties dans les financements
qu'est-ce qui peut expliquer qu'il n'y
ait pas des règles du jeu dans les
financements que vous apportez monsieur
le député merci beaucoup monsieur le
député pour les républicains monsieur
Julien dive merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur ministre 30 à 40 000 c'est le
nombre d'emplois qui sont supprimés
chaque année en France avec les deux
localisations particulièrement des
multinationales qui s'y emploient et
notamment lorsqu'il y a des périodes de
crise peut-être est l'un des angles
morts de ce texte c'est justement la
lutte contre ces délocalisations vous
avez rappelé que il fallait des
carbonner notre industrie le meilleur
moyen de décarboner notre industrie
notre économie notre tissu industrielle
c'est de lutter aussi contre les
importations et donc de favoriser les
entreprises en place et lutter au mieux
contre les délocalisations j'avais
moi-même formulé quelques amendements
qui ont été recevables c'est pas grave
j'en ferai pas une maladie ni une crise
mais j'aimerais que vous puissiez nous
donner des éléments monsieur le ministre
sur cette question de la délocalisation
et la lutte contre ces délocalisation
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
horizon 20 sentier beau oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre nous nous régissons nous notre
sur cette loi effectivement qui était
censée puisque aujourd'hui quelques
années nous recréons des emplois dans
l'industrie pour ce qui dit et surtout
nous nous responsabilisons par rapport à
l'industrie par rapport à
l'industrialisation et la production
toutefois nous avons une interrogation
gin interrogation notamment sur le sujet
de la logistique qui n'apparaît pas
forcément ce texte mais tout à fait
essentiel notamment au bien maîtriser
les flux de transfert effectivement en
train industriels mais aussi entre sites
industriels est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner quelques points sur ce sujet qui
est pour l'instant pas exprimer dans le
texte merci beaucoup merci monsieur le
député pour le groupe
GDR Monsieur Hubert villefranc si vapeur
vapeur charbon charbon pétrole pétrole
électricité on est aujourd'hui en fait
sur un projet de loi qui aborde la
transformation du système une technique
du capital bon contact mais il y a la
question majeure du recours à l'argent
public que nous aurions souhaité poser
d'emblée deux manques majeurs dans votre
projet de loi en plus des autres
effectivement en amont du produit fini
la question des mannequins première des
terres et la question des industries
extractives dans notre pays qui est posé
aujourd'hui et qui est totalement
absente de votre propos et on avale du
produit fini la question comme tu l'as
dit des transports ferrés fluvio de la
logistique qui est un enjeu majeur parce
que le produit il sort de la boutique
mais si il sort un camion aussi il sort
en train c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose donc là il y a un enjeu là encore
totalement pas ses soucis lance des
questions qu'on va aborder
merci monsieur le député pour le groupe
Liot Monsieur Charles Amédée de Courson
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre votre article 17 est une bonne
idée qui vise à fixer un taux minimum de
d'utilisation des assurances vie et des
plans d'épargne retraite vers
les petits et moyennes entreprises cette
idée nous l'avons eu dès 1993
non mais je vous raconte parce que c'est
pittoresque
et nous avons essayé de fixé les taux il
est pas il était pas encore né à la
politique mais bon voilà
et et on avait d'ailleurs déposé des
amendements et le ministre des Finances
de l'époque nous a dit mais il faut
laisser ça va être fait ça va être fait
30 ans plus tard on est à 1,3 %
des 1839 milliards d'assurance vie et
c'est quand même beaucoup mieux deux et
demi pour cent des PER bon donc moi je
crois que le Sénat avait amendé pour
dire que le ministre fixerait un taux
minimum je pensais pas un taux fini même
qu'il faut fixer c'est un taux minimum
progressif s'il vous plaît alors nous
comptons sur vous pour appuyer nos
amendements en ce sens merci monsieur le
député enfin pour le groupe
rassemblement national monsieur
Jean-Philippe Tanguy
oui merci monsieur le Président nos
collègues ont évoqué l'insuffisance
programmation des questions de formation
mais il y a deux autres facteurs de
production qui me sont pas du tout au
niveau d'une planification de
réindustrialisation c'est la question
évidemment cruciale des matières
premières en particulier des métaux et
encore plus particulièrement des métaux
rares il y a un refus d'envisager la
production l'extraction de matière
première de manière durable et
écologique puisqu'on maîtriserait les
facteurs de production sur notre
territoire et deuxième critère c'est
évidemment la production d'énergie
comprennent les scénarios de RTE même le
dernier scénario de RTE qui s'est aligné
sur les prévisions de Marine Le Pen à la
présidentielle il n'y a pas de quoi
aujourd'hui alimenter des usines
électrifier et des productions des
carbonées bah oui ça vous fait mal mais
c'est vrai qu'on a toujours raison je
comprends d'ailleurs c'est l'objet de ce
texte de loi en fait c'est le fait qu'on
est toujours raison donc comme on a
toujours raison il faut prévoir
l'approvision d'un tiers première et
l'approvision de d'énergie et merci
quand je peux pas en place au moins je
fais remarquer que nous avons toujours
raison j'en le dirai je le dirai autant
de fois qu'il faudra merci beaucoup
monsieur le député enfin pour conclure
cette fois j'espère monsieur
ah il y a Monsieur le seul aussi
d'abord Monsieur Emmanuel Berry pour le
rassemblement national merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je
profite vous avez parlé du maintien de
l'emploi dans les industries existantes
et je voudrais vous parler de Tereos
vous abordé le sujet vous avez dit on va
essayer de maintenir les emplois mais
j'aimerais savoir comment parce que vous
savez très bien que le la fin de tairos
en tout cas et code donc 123 emplois
c'est bien lié à la crise des LNI en
fait donc c'est la fin de l'utilisation
des nni vous entendez oui
alors soit vous allez revenir sur cette
décision voilà ce que je ne crois pas ou
alors vous avouez un forfait finalement
vous allez nous dire peut-être que c'est
123 emplois va être rebootés vers
d'autres industries justement mais
j'aimerais vraiment un éclaircissement
là dessus parce que vous êtes engagé à
dire que vous allez regarder ce dossier
de prêt j'attends votre réponse merci
merci monsieur le député j'ai
l'impression que vous avez pas envie
qu'on commence le texte ce soir donc
la concertation la consultation pourquoi
ne pas avoir fait une grande conférence
nationale sur l'industrie merci Monsieur
le seul pour le groupe GDR monsieur
Sébastien Jumel
ça a été dit plein de fois mais comme on
n'a pas de réponse je retente ma chance
c'était pas le moment au moment des unr
de parler de formation c'était pas le
moment au moment du projet de loi
d'accélération du nucléaire de parler
des métiers du nucléaire cent mille en
poissons nécessaires et c'est pas le
moment au moment du texte sur
l'industrie verte de parler de ça enfin
quand est-ce que ce sera le moment c'est
pas peine c'est pas pas peine bien qu'il
va s'occuper de ça bah sinon il aurait
déjà fait donc ça c'est le premier sujet
pas de réindustrialisation possible sans
formation et sans formation liées au
métier deuxième
question
pas de réindustrialisation pas de
relocalisation des boîtes pas de
verdissement de l'industrie sans
politique énergétique sans visibilité
sur les prix et sans reprise en main
d'un mix énergétique au service d'une
industrie des carbonée rien dans le
texte là-dessus non plus c'est renvoyé
à PPE à je ne sais quoi enfin je ne sais
quand merci monsieur le député pas
d'autre prise de parole merci Monsieur
le Ministre la parole est à vous
merci monsieur le Président et merci à
tous et à toutes pour vos remarques et
questions madame la députée la député
pardon peut être levain vous êtes de
Haute-Savoie la vallée de l'arche c'est
ça
que j'ai eu l'occasion de visiter il y a
quelques mois avec Bruno Le Maire c'est
une des industries qui va être au cœur
de la transition aujourd'hui extrêmement
orienté vers les véhicules thermiques et
il faut qu'on les appuis dans la
réorientation vers d'autres secteurs il
y a des enjeux de consolidation dans ce
secteur on sait qu'il y a des très
belles entreprises dans la vallée larve
et d'autres qui sont plus petites qui
vont sans doute avoir du mal je dirais à
passer la colline il faut vraiment qu'on
les appuie de manière à pouvoir
consolider davantage ce secteur mais il
faut surtout les accompagner dans la
diversification j'ai vu une entreprise
dans votre région je sais pas si c'était
votre circonscription qui aujourd'hui
fait des pièces pour les véhicules
thermiques qui est en train de se
diversifier vers les vélos électriques
et qui fait des moteurs électriques pour
des vélos vous la connaissez sans doute
elle est extrêmement
productive
inspirante et notamment pour répondre
rapidement mais je vais y revenir tout à
l'heure sur les réseaux de formation à
l'organise aussi la transition de ces
salariés vers de nouveaux métiers
donc on a aujourd'hui des régions dans
lequel les entrepreneurs se prennent je
dirais
en main pour assurer cette transition et
nous allons les accompagner vous avez
posé une bonne question sur le BGS en
revanche je pense que vous avez
mentionné une disposition du texte qui
n'y est pas encore et qui j'espère n'y
sera pas vous avez parlé de bulletins
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
obligatoire pour candidater à la
commande publique ce n'est pas dans le
texte il y a des amendements certains
qui viennent d'autres bancs qui visent à
rendre obligatoire l'émission d'un BGS
pour la commande publique nous n'avons
pas souhaité la rendre obligataire
exactement pour les raisons que vous
mentionnez
aujourd'hui un acheteur public qui
souhaite que les entreprises qui
candidatent frontale sur les gars de la
SNCF il va pouvoir le faire grâce à ce
projet de loi il ne va pas être obligé
de le faire parce que s'il est obligé de
le faire on risque de se retrouver avec
des entreprises que vous mentionnez qui
n'ont pas encore eu le temps de faire
leur bulletin qui seront de fait exclus
de marcher public et ces obligations ne
s'imposerait en rien à des entreprises
qui viendraient de l'étranger
d'Allemagne Italie ou d'ailleurs et donc
on aurait de fait un favoritisme de fait
pour des entreprises étrangères donc
nous ne souhaitons pas aller jusque là
mais nous aurons le débat dans le cadre
de l'article en question madame
Bonnivard vous avez parlé des industries
électro intensives
j'ai évidemment en tête notre visite
commune à Saint-Jean-de-Maurienne à
l'entreprise trimestre une aluminerie
extrêmement performante des carbonée et
nous y étions il y a 10 jours ensemble
parce que cette entreprise c'est très
important y compris pour votre question
monsieur jumelles sur la fixation des
prix dans l'énergie
essentiel trimestre a signé avec EDF un
contrat vous y étiez nous y étions qui
va lui attirer d'assurer pardon des
volumes d'électricité à des prix
compétitifs pour les années qui viennent
ça fait 10 ans qu'ils avaient un contrat
ensemble qui avait été signé au moment
de la reprise de trimestre par un
actionnaire allemand d'extrême qualité
qui était là aussi il y a 10 jours ils
se sont engagés pour les 10 ans qui
viennent à des volumes bien précis avec
des prix des firmes de concurrence cet
exemple de trimestre on doit le
généraliser et donc je sais plus je
pense que c'est vous madame la député
qui me demandait sur qu'est-ce qui
arrive après la reine ce qui arrive
après la reine
ce sera des contrats de long terme il
faut qu'on puisse faire en sorte
après la reine c'est le roi le roi du
pétrole non EDF et donc on est vraiment
aujourd'hui entre un je pense avec
trimestre de montrer l'exemple on a
besoin d'assurer que quand on fait des
contrats de ce type là il y a un partage
du risque entre le producteur et
consommateur vous le savez c'est
important pour bien montrer à la
Commission européenne qu'on n'est pas en
train de faire des des subventions
induites à nos industriels mais cet
exemple doit être suivi pour tous les
électrons intensifs petits moyens ou
grand d'ailleurs
madame la députée gaîté et un certain
nombre d'autres y compris monsieur
maisonnet monsieur Tanguy et je pense
monsieur
le seul et Monsieur jumelle m'avait
interpellé sur le fait qu'on parle pas
le formation dans cette dans ce projet
de loi
la formation la transition n'est talons
je suis désolé mais on en parle pas on
le fait depuis 5 ans on a triplé le
nombre d'apprentis en France et
notamment évidemment pour plus de 20%
d'entre eux dans les secteurs
industriels on a aujourd'hui pas loin de
200 000 apprentis en France qui sont en
train de s'orienter vers l'industrie on
va continuer à le faire en formant
davantage et pour ça il n'y a pas besoin
de loi mesdames et messieurs les députés
je comprends votre frustration de pas
pouvoir débattre de ce sujet mais
n'hésitez pas dans le cadre de vos
opérations de contrôle à faire venir les
ministres et à les auditionner mais
quand je vous dis qu'on va ajouter 20%
d'ingénieurs dans toutes les écoles des
mines ça coûtera pas un milliard madame
ghetter le budget global des Écoles des
Mines aujourd'hui c'est 300 millions
donc ça fera à peu près 20% de 300
millions je vous donnerai pas le chiffre
exact parce qu'évidemment tout ça
devrait être précisé mais c'est l'ordre
de grandeur donc on est loin du milliard
en revanche le milliard en fait les deux
milliards en fait les 2 milliards et
demi qu'on a mis dans l'appel à
manifestation d'intérêt dans France 2030
pour les compétences et les métiers
d'avenir dont on a déjà lancé une
première vague à 750 millions cela ils
existent ils sont en train aujourd'hui
d'accompagner des entreprises
d'accompagner des écoles d'accompagner
des CFA d'accompagner des écoles de
production qui sont en train de former
nos jeunes et nos moins jeunes aux
métiers d'avenir donc n'hésitez pas à
faire vos boulots de contrôle faites
venir les ministres autant que vous
voulez pour les interroger ou Bruno
Bonnel secrétaire général de
l'investissement pour l'auditionner sur
la manière dont cet argent à dépenser
mais ce que je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est que nous faisons et
qu'on va continuer à faire on va faire
la réforme des lycées professionnels
n'hésitez pas à la soutenir madame
guetter n'hésitez pas à le soutenir
monsieur maisonnet nous voulons que les
lycées professionnels forment davantage
à l'industrie aujourd'hui les lycées
professionnels c'est insuffisant de
formation vers des métiers techniques
pour lequel il y a de l'emploi il y a
des perspectives de carrière ça paye
mieux donc n'hésitez pas à soutenir
cette superbe
réforme
je laisserai le président répondre sur
les questions qu'il concernaient
en ce qui concerne monsieur dragon et
votre question sur la l'entreprise
whocoules qui bénéficie aujourd'hui
d'une autorisation environnementale
délivrée en avril 2021 mais qui fait
face à deux recours un France naturant
et un du collectif dit sauvons Soissons
motif la vie défavorable du commestaire
rentable un enquêteur pardon car
justification insuffisante du choix du
site le jugement au fond est attendu le
22 juillet donc évidemment je me
présenterai je ne prononcerai pas sur
une entre une procédure judiciaire en
cours dont le résultat sera connu le 22
juillet ce que je peux vous dire en
revanche c'est qu'on touche du doigt là
l'ensemble des enjeux qu'on a mentionnés
depuis quelques heures c'est qu'on a
besoin d'aligner l'ensemble des élus
nationaux régionaux départementaux et
locaux autour de ces projets industriels
moi je le fais tous les jours quand je
vais dans les hauts de France quand je
vais en Occitanie je change
régulièrement avec les présidents de
région j'échange régulièrement avec les
président appartement j'ai des réunions
avec tous les élus locaux certains
d'entre vous étaient sans doute à Caudry
abuttoni ou Havre quand on a eu ces
réunions là il est essentiel qu'on
aligne tout le monde ce qui est vrai
c'est que ce projet de recul aujourd'hui
il fait l'objet d'un certain nombre de
résistance de la part des élus locaux
peut-être que l'entreprise d'ailleurs a
insuffisamment son train fait son
travail de partage avec les élus donc je
langage à continuer à le faire mais
d'ici le 22 juillet en tout cas on
attend le résultat
de l'audience juridique monsieur Tavel a
mentionné la formation La formation les
droits des salariés
vraiment
je passe une deux à trois fois par
semaine montant dans les usines et à
chaque fois je rencontre les salariés et
à chaque fois je rencontre les
représentants les organisations
syndicales ils adhèrent à notre projet
ils nous remercient pour ce qu'on a fait
depuis quelques années pour sauver
l'industrie ça vous fait marrer monsieur
Tavel mais je peux vous dire que des uns
des entreprises j'y vais tous les jours
et que les usines et Monsieur jumelles
le sait bien
[Musique]
des discussions sur l'organisation du
travail qu'on organisation qu'on
accompagne dans l'évolution des
carrières et moi je suis tout à fait
prêt à avoir ces conversations sont pas
des conversations de type législatif
monsieur Tavel je suis désolé non moi je
crois et je pense que vous aussi au
dialogue social je veux dire le dialogue
social il se fait dans les branches il
se fait dans les entreprises il se fait
pas à l'Assemblée d'ailleurs la dernière
fois que j'ai vérifié les syndicats n'y
étaient pas représentés et je comprends
votre frustration mais c'est comme ça la
loi n'est pas là je suis convaincu en
tout cas pour gérer les enjeux de
dialogue social vous m'avez interrogé
sur sur les sites ce vaisseaux et la
la création d'une autorité indépendante
vous savez qu'elle existe pour le
nucléaire elle existe pour nucléaire
parce que l'entreprise qui elle-même
construit et opère les réacteurs
nucléaires étant public nous avons
souhaité depuis des années avoir une
autorité indépendante qui en juge
aujourd'hui c'est le ministère de
l'Environnement qui contrôle qui suit
l'exécution et le respect des
contraintes ces vaisseaux ça me semble
tout à fait normal pour des entreprises
privées aujourd'hui qui opèrent sur le
territoire on n'a pas besoin de déléguer
tous les contrôles à des autorités
indépendantes monsieur le député Charles
Fournier moi j'ai pas de modèle unique
la gigafactory très bien des centaines
de milliers de batteries qui vont être
produites en France avec dans quelques
années j'ai été interrogé là-dessus par
Monsieur Tanguy je vais revenir des
matières premières recyclées des
matériaux de base recyclés du lithium
sans doute en partie produit en France
j'ai rien contre mais évidemment qu'on
accompagne aussi les PME les entreprises
de taille intermédiaires moi j'ai
inauguré une usine flambant neuf il y a
un an il pardon l'usine Lacroix dans le
dans le Maine-et-Loire qui fait de la
microélectronique il y a pas que du ST
dans la vie il y a aussi l'entreprise la
croix et moi je souhaite vraiment qu'on
oppose pas les entreprises les unes aux
autres on oppose pas les territoires les
unes aux autres on va développer
l'ensemble de l'industrie en France on
va vers dire l'ensemble de l'industrie
on accompagne dans le cadre de France
2030 les grossites et les plus petits et
j'espère qu'on va avoir votre soutien
sur tout ça en ce qui concerne la
conditionnalité je pense qu'on va y
revenir dans le cadre de l'examen du
texte mais St comme beaucoup d'autres
ces aides sont conditionnées il y a des
conditions qu'on appelle des conditions
de globale qui font que si St par
exemple se délocalise j'ai une question
de Monsieur dive là-dessus évidemment il
devra rembourser les aides donc l'idée
selon laquelle aujourd'hui l'État
français fait depuis des années des
chèques en blanc aux entreprises elle
est fausse il y a des choses sur lequel
nous ne serons pas d'accord les
allègements de charge je sais que vous y
êtes opposé monsieur jumelles
souhaiterait les conditionner je suis
sûr que
un certain nombre d'autres députés ici
présents sur les bancs de la gauche
souhaiteraient les conditionner soyez et
peut-être sur la droite soyons d'accord
pour pas être d'accord là-dessus mais
les aides dont on parle aujourd'hui les
aides dont on parle aujourd'hui elles
sont toutes conditionnées toutes ben ça
dépend des projets évidemment quand vous
ben je vais je vais peut-être pas vous
lister les conditions de tous les
projets industriels mais aujourd'hui
évidemment la relocalisation des projets
comme celui de St l'aide publique c'est
pas un chèque en blanc elle est
conditionnée ne serait-ce qu'au faite
que le projet se fasse et qui se fasse
en France par exemple donc voilà en ce
qui concerne Photowatt vous le savez
sans doute on travaille sur différents
scénarios de restructuration et de
croissance avec EDF j'ai eu l'occasion
d'échanger là-dessus avec le PDG d'EDF
qu'il l'a annoncé en Comité Social
d'Entreprise
monsieur Thibault non traite pas de
logistique c'est vrai que la logistique
pour nous ça ne fait pas partie des
secteurs industriels on peut traiter le
logistique par ailleurs moi je non mais
bien sûr et d'ailleurs le comité
stratégique de logistique que je
co-anime avec les membres il a pas
attendu la loi industrie verte pour
s'intéresser aux enjeux logistiques bien
sûr quand on peut arrêter les
interpellations s'il vous plaît quand on
crée mais si Monsieur jumelles
monsieur jumelles on vous a laissé vous
exprimer autant que vous vouliez
qui a été le dernier à poser sa question
donc
évidemment que la logistique est
importante évidemment que par exemple
quand on donne une subvention zone
industrielle bacarbone à Dunkerque au
Havre ou ailleurs ils intègre la
logistique dans leur réflexion mais je
ne considère pas que la logistique soit
une activité industrielle à forte valeur
ajoutée qui soit dans le champ de ce
projet de loi on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'en discuter encore j'ai pas
entendu de questions très précise de la
part de le député ville Francis non ces
critique sur la dépense de l'argent
public j'espère y avoir répondu en
partie sur la conditionnalité d'Eden en
ce qui concerne la question de Charles
Amédée de Courson j'entends ce que vous
dites développez l'investissement dans
les PME et notamment et surtout
développer l'investissement dans le non
coté dans les entreprises familiales qui
ne souhaitent pas aller sur les marchés
financiers c'est un des enjeux majeurs
ça fait des années qu'on y travaille
vous l'avez dit quand même le PER qui
est un produit créé par la loi pacte qui
a moins de 5 ans a plutôt progressé à
plutôt permis de progresser parce qu'un
certain nombre d'amendements d'ailleurs
y incitait les assurances on est
aujourd'hui à 2,5 %, il faut qu'on
continue à développer ça j'ai peur moi
que forcer le trait et inciter je dirais
obligé pardon un pourcentage minimum
dans ces entreprises
exclut à certains nombre d'entreprises
financières et notamment des plus
petites qui n'ont pas forcément toute la
gamme de produits nécessaires ou en tout
cas pas la profondeur de marché
nécessaire de ce type d'investissement
on aura l'occasion je n'en doute pas d'y
revenir dans le cadre de la discussion
de l'article 17 monsieur le député
Tanguy
vous avez raison je pense pas que vous
ayez toujours raison je pense que même
vous avez souvent tort mais vous avez
raison les matières premières ça va être
l'honneur de la guerre et merci
d'ailleurs de ce fait de vous être très
largement inspiré dans votre question
d'un rapport que nous avions commandé le
rapport Varin qui faisait exactement les
préconisations que vous faites
aujourd'hui ce rapport il a deux ans il
est en train d'être mis en oeuvre il ne
nécessite en aucun cas de disposition
législative j'ai nommé un délégué
interministériel au matériaux de base
c'était une recommandation du rapport
varan nous avons lancé un fond de 500
millions d'euros d'argent public qui va
être complété par 500 millions d'argent
privé de cette année et 1 milliard
l'année prochaine qui va être géré par
un gestionnaire de front infravia qui va
développer
notre capacité à disposer des matériaux
de base critiques qui vont nous
permettre de décarboner l'industrie
traditionnelle certains de ces matériaux
viendront de l'étranger
mais seront de toute façon collectés
dans une logique de mining d'extraction
responsable et d'autres seront sans
doute extraits en France on a beaucoup
de lithium en France faisons-le de
manière responsable assurons-nous que
les populations sont prêtes à jouer le
jeu mais évidemment nous avons des
ressources exceptionnelles qui va
falloir
exploiter dans le cadre de ce dans le
cadre de cette ce verdissement de
l'industrie
et je vous engage d'ailleurs puisque
vous avez déjà suivi le rapport Varin à
suivre aussi Bruno Le Maire qui
récemment été en Allemagne et qui a
convenu avec son homologue allemand du
fait que là dessus encore monsieur
instant school on devait avoir une
stratégie européenne l'Europe doit être
indépendante pour ces matériaux de base
l'Europe doit aussi mettre en place du
recyclage de ces matériaux de base de
manière à ce que elle soit à la fois
exemplaire et plus présente chez eux on
a aujourd'hui 11 projets soutenus par
France 2030 pour le lithium
[Musique]
la seule chose que je peux vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on y travaille et
qu'on y travaille fort j'ai rencontré
les organisations syndicales géant
rencontré la direction malheureusement
si c'était les néonicotinoïdes ça serait
ça serait bien simple la réalité et je
leur ai dit et je l'ai dit publiquement
c'est qu'on a une direction qui a commis
un certain nombre d'erreurs stratégiques
car insuffisamment investi dans le guide
production qui a décidé de fermer
aujourd'hui un site qui n'est plus
compétitif je travaille aujourd'hui
d'arrache-pied avec la direction avec le
territoire avec tous les élus pour qu'on
ait une solution pour chacun des
salariés concernés et pour le site à
suivre
monsieur le seul vous aviez évoqué la
formation je pense que j'ai répondu
conférence nationale sur l'industrie moi
je pense que ce projet de loi doit
pouvoir nous permettre d'avoir des
débats intéressants fouiller j'espère
qu'on s'en suita sur notre objectif
commun qui est de réindustrialiser la
France faisons-le faisons le faisons-le
et Monsieur jumelles nous travaillons
sur la formation nous travaillons sur
l'éducation et je vais vous faire une
confidence papaine Guy le fait aussi en
novembre dernier semaine dans
l'industrie mille jeunes qui venait des
quartiers qu'on a fait rencontrer à des
industriels Pape Ndiaye et moi au
ministère des Finances ils sont tous
sortis avec de l'envie d'industrie
faisons-nous tous moi je suis prêt à le
faire dans toutes vos circonscriptions
rapprochons l'école de l'industrie
rapprochons l'industrie de l'école
donnons envie à nos jeunes d'industrie
on y arrivera ensemble où on y arrivera
pas merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre alors pour
répondre à notre ami à notre ami député
Pierre Meurin et pour répondre
finalement à tous ceux qui auraient des
remarques à faire
sur Lire saveur à éviter c'est dur à ce
temps là au nom de l'article 45 je tiens
à vous préciser que tout le travail qui
a été fait il a été fait avec en
parfaite impartialité en toute honnêteté
et si vous voulez si vous voulez et
c'est dommage qu'elle soit partie parce
que Madame guetter et Madame Dufour
aurait pu en témoigner si vous voulez
des explications sur certains des
amendements qui ont été jugés
irrecevables et vous ne comprenez pas
pourquoi vous nous écrivez et nous vous
répondons c'est ce que nous avons fait
notamment pour Madame guetter et pour
Madame Dufour cet après-midi bien chers
collègues je pense que nous allons
abréger vos souffrances pour ce soir et
nous allons nous retrouver donc demain
matin
9h30
ici même salle même punition et même
endroit merci à vous tous